Höchste Zeit und wir sind wieder mal genial
Tut uns wund'bar leid
Wie immer Schauer als der Rest
Also bitte keine Neid
Halt die beste Band der Welt
Euerner Bescheidenheit
Hangt ihr euch hier viel
Hakt ihr uns vermisst
Ist euch jetzt klar
Das Bild um die Welt schöner ist
Seid ihr wieder froh
Na, was für ein Glück
Wir sagen Hallo
Denn wir sind zurück
Wir sind da
Wir sind wieder da
Wir lungern nur im Schulgang
Rufverkauf und kleinen Kinn entkriegt
Wir singen unsichtige Lieder
Und gehen ab ins laue Welt
Tischmanieren sind uns krank
Wir essen selten mit Besteck
Die Plattenfirma schickt uns jedes Jahr
In die Geschichte
Hakt ihr uns vermisst
Hakt ihr euch hier viel
Hakt ihr heimlich geweiht
Und die Tage gibt's her
Wir sind zurück
Und es riecht nach Kugeln
Denn die Ärzte aus den Häusern
Wie ein Hagelsturm
Alleine Sommertag
Wie ein trötzlicher Wind
Die einen finden Scheiße
Die anderen finden Stahl
Genau wie jedes Jahr
Wir sind wieder da
Es ging ums verrecken gegen mein Mikro nicht.
Und wisst ihr woran das lag?
Ratet mal! Ratet mal woran das lag.
Da kommt ihr nie drauf.
Das ist zwar so ein typischer Windows
und so ein typischer Windows Crap.
Was witzig war...
Also ich mein wir machen jetzt mal ein bisschen Windows Flame.
Windows Flame kann nie schaden.
Wisst ihr überhaupt wie kompliziert das mittlerweile ist?
In das Menü zu kommen, wo man
wirklich Sound-Settings einstellen kann?
Also zum Beispiel,
wenn ihr einstellen wollt,
welche Frequenz,
ähm, äh nicht Frequenz.
Wie heißt denn das? Welche Abtastrate
euer Sound verwenden soll.
Was wichtig ist,
wenn man zum Beispiel per optischen,
per Tosslink an einem Audio-Interfest dran ist.
Wisst ihr wo das mittlerweile geht?
Passt mal auf hier. Ich hoffe mal, ich finde das überhaupt.
Mikro war deaktiviert.
Ne, ne, ne. Mikro ging.
Also man muss jetzt hier rechts drauf klicken.
Rechts drauf klicken.
Mik... ne.
Ne, Moment.
Muss jetzt hier Open Sound-Settings machen.
Sound-Control Panel.
Dann geht das, dann geht das olle Ding auf.
Ja, Timilius, das ist gar nicht so schlecht,
was du da vermutest.
Privacy-Einstellung fürs Mikrofon.
So, dann muss man das aufmachen.
Ähm...
So, und dann habe ich hier nachgeguckt
und habe damals festgestellt, dass hier mein Mikrofon
war aktiviert und alles gut,
aber es hat keinen Ausschlag gehabt.
Das ging nicht, das hat nicht funktioniert.
Na, man kann sich das Mikrofon mal entscheiden.
Angeblich ist das voll leise, ne?
Angeblich ist das voll leise.
Allerdings OBS sagt, es ist fast schon zu laut.
Wo man sich sagen muss,
was?
Muss das jetzt irgendjemand verstehen?
Egal, wem noch ist Logik.
Scheiß drauf. So.
Und dann habe ich festgestellt, ey,
wenn ich hier in die Settings gehe
und Listen to this device mache,
pass auf, dann gibt es ein Echo, muss man jetzt aufpassen.
So, Echo, Echo.
Echo, Echo, Echo.
Dann hat...
Okay, aus. Dann hat es funktioniert.
Dann hat es funktioniert.
Aber es hat nicht normal funktioniert.
So, und dann habe ich echt, also meine Leitung,
bis ich dieses Menü hier gefunden habe.
Wenn man sich fragt, warum man teilweise
Soundaussetzer hat oder
ähm, das ist, das ist
knistert, knastert, wie auch immer,
knistert, beim optischen
Soundausgang, da muss man nämlich hier auf Playback
gehen, auf Digital Audio
und dann auf...
Das hier ist, das ist fake, das stimmt nicht.
Man muss auf Advanced
und guckt hier, guckt euch mal an.
Das ist Microsoft Big Brain, ja?
Supported Format
48 Kilohertz
Default Format
44,1 Kilohertz.
Wo ist die Logik, Microsoft?
Wo ist die Logik? Ich verstehe es nicht.
Aber so funktioniert, anders
funktioniert es nicht. Das heißt, in dieses
Menü muss man sich irgendwie vorarbeiten,
dass man
das ändern kann.
So, und zumindest, das Problem,
was ich hatte mit meinem Windows, warum das mit
dem Mikrofon nicht funktioniert hat, war...
Äh...
Ich meine, vor allem, was ist das
schon wieder für ein komisches Menü, wozu ist das überhaupt da?
Ähm...
Scheiße, wo war das denn
jetzt?
Das ist übrigens voll doppelt,
ne? Es gibt hier diese Settings,
es gibt diese Settings, es gibt
hier unten die Settings und den Mixer.
Ach du Scheiße, wo war das denn jetzt?
Privacy Settings für Mikro... für, für, für
Mikrofon.
Ja, Microphone Privacy
Settings.
Und da stand, Allow
Apps to Access Your Microphone stand auf
Off.
Wer denkt denn daran, dass deswegen sein Mikrofon
nicht geht? Jaja,
ich hab das ja nicht eingestellt. Nach dem Update.
Und wo man es übrigens dran erkennt, ist
an diesem Icon hier unten.
Wenn das Icon hier unten da ist,
ist es eingeschaltet.
Dumm nur, dass das Icon standardmäßig
hier drin ist.
Ähm...
Und, und wenn man das hier ausschaltet,
was ich jetzt nicht mache, weil da kackt wahrscheinlich OBS ab,
dann ist das Icon hier unten auch weg.
Leute, ich hab drei oder vier Stunden gesucht,
bis ich den Scheiß gefunden hab,
weil der Witz war ja, ja? Auf meinem
Streaming-Account hat alles funktioniert, ne?
Ich wollte mit dem Eax irgendwas, irgendwas...
Ne, ne, ne, ne, nicht mal mit dem Eax, bitte mit dem...
Mit dem M-Core wollte ich damals eine Runde Discord labern.
Und das hat ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert.
Das ging einfach nicht.
Und da bin ich dann extra auf meinem Streaming-Account umgelockt,
dass ich mit dem labern konnte im Discord, weil es
auf dem Haupt-Account ums Verrecken nicht funktioniert hat.
Bis ich dann irgendwann mal drauf gekommen bin,
weil ich genauso wie hier einfach mal
ein Mikrophone gesucht hab und zufällig hier reingegangen bin,
dass es hier auf Off steht.
Was? Warum?
Und vor allem, es gibt ja immer...
Du kannst ja hier sagen, in Sound kannst du irgendwie...
Ich weiß gar nicht, oder? Hier.
Hier kannst du sagen, set up your microphone,
oder set up a micro... Ne, kannst du nicht.
Äh.
Picks your sound problems.
Ne, fuck. Wo ist das?
Man kann so einen komischen Assistent starten,
man kann nicht so einen komischen Assistent starten,
der einem versucht das Mikrophone
einzurichten.
Und der Assistent ist abgestürzt.
Der ist immer abgekackt, der Assistent.
Also ich mein, es wäre hier irgendwie sinnvoll,
wenn Windows das umgedreht machen würde,
ein Icon, so nach dem Motto hier,
Mikrophone ist an,
und ein Icon, hallo,
Mikrophone ist ausgeschaltet,
nur dass du es einfach siehst.
Aber du siehst, vergisst es, du siehst das nicht.
Also ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz mir.
Mocker win.
Echt, also...
Ich weiß manchmal echt nicht,
was mit Microsoft abgeht, wenn sich sowas ausdenkt.
Es ist ja auch schon grausam, wenn du dir das hier anguckst,
teilweise, wie viele alte,
richtig alte, mittelalte und
neue und ganz neue User-Interfaces
unter Windows gemixt sind.
Und außerdem denkt sich ja Microsoft gerne was,
gerne was Neues aus, wie ihre Oberfläche aussehen muss.
Du hast mich im vorletzten Video
mit deiner Microtech-Zucht angesteckt,
die Router sind mega nice.
Sagt er...
Luxi...
Zu...
Luckyzu?
Ja, die sind mega nice, vor allem für das Geld.
Wäre cool, wenn du mal ein bisschen RouterOS zeigst.
Würde mir auch gerne ein Router...
Du kannst...
Wenn du dich interessierst, dafür will das aussehen.
Die haben eine RouterOS-Demo,
die ist ziemlich praktisch.
Hier.
Einfach auf OK drücken.
Hier kannst du dir das angucken.
Kannst du rumbasteln.
Ich kann schlecht
meine Router-Settings im Stream zeigen.
Ich weiß nämlich nicht, ob da nicht
irgendwas drinsteht, weil ich nicht will, dass man das sieht.
Im Prinzip ist Windows
auch gar nicht so schlimm.
Die Details sind das, was in Windows sackt.
Gibt es heute auch ein
Hannah-Montana-Linux?
Wann wurde das zuletzt geupdatet?
Also ganz, ganz via.
So.
Übrigens, ich habe ein richtig cooles Video
letztens auf YouTube gesehen.
Der hat die Geschichte
von Mario Kart Rage
from Mario Kart Rage
Ja ja leider, das kommt ja nicht drumherum.
Kabelmodem kaufen mach ich nicht.
Ist mir auch zu blöd, noch ein extra Gerät hinzustellen.
Ich mein es gibt jetzt ja, seit neuestem wieder hab ich gelesen von Tri-Tec diese...
Wie spricht man überhaupt aus?
Gibt jetzt ja jetzt wieder ein Kabelmodem zu kaufen bei denen?
Gar nicht welches das war.
Kann ich jetzt überhaupt hier irgendwo drinne stehen?
Das da, ne?
Allerdings...
Weiß gar nicht wie das heißt von denen.
Aber ich hab kein Bock noch ein extra Gerät hinzustellen.
Guck mal, es ist irgendwie total beknackt.
Nur um ein theoretisch saubereres Setup zu haben, drei Geräte zu betreiben irgendwie.
Für was ist ein zweiter Router sinnvoll?
Na ja gut, wenn man einen gescheiten Router haben will.
Fritzbox ist kein gescheiter Router, wenn man was mit WLAN-Unterstützung zum Beispiel haben will.
Was essentiell dafür ist, wenn man mehrere WLANs haben will.
Außer dieses komische Gäste-WLAN von der Fritzbox.
Die Fritzbox ist ein ziemlicher scheiß Router.
Was die Fritzbox gut macht ist, die Fritzbox ist ein super Multifunktionsgerät.
Kabel-Shooter?
Was ist mit denen los?
Ihh, es ist Windows 98!
Also ich weiß gar nicht wie das von denen hieß.
Aber da seh ich nicht ein.
Zumindest ich mach das so.
Wie gesagt, ich werd am nächstes umgestellt von Unity Media.
Von 100 Down und 5 Up auf 400 Down und 40 Up.
Und ich werd bei denen gleich sagen, ich will meine eigene Fritzbox verwenden.
Dann fällt schon mal dieses komische Technicolor-Unity Media-Router weg.
Das Ding ist übelster Crap.
Das ist wirklich, das ist das Ding hier.
Da hatten bestimmt schon Leute Freude mit diesem tollen Gerät.
Ja, das da. Alter, so ein Crap hab ich selten gesehen, ey.
Das ist wirklich das räudigste Modem aller Zeiten, was es gibt.
Also das ist, das ist abartig.
Der WLAN ist eh ausgeschaltet bei dem Ding.
Deswegen werd ich's jetzt so machen.
Ähm, ich, wenn die mich umstellen,
werd ich denen auch gleich sagen, ich will einen eigenen, eigenen Router betreiben.
Darf man ja, ja, ist kein Ding.
Also mittlerweile ist es ja sogar gesetzlich vorgeschrieben, dass sie das einmal erlauben müssen.
Dann werd ich mir ne eigene Kabelfritzbox dran machen, muss ich noch bestellen.
Weil ich brauch die halt für, für, ähm, Decktelefone.
Ansonsten, für sonst eigentlich nix.
Und dahinter kommt da mein Mikrotik-Router.
Und ich werd's halt so machen, dass die Fritzbox macht halt den Ausgang zu Unity Media.
Also sprich, die Fritzbox macht NAT ins Internet.
Und der, äh, Mikrotik-Router, da macht halt das, was er gut kann.
Der routet halt einfach.
Mit Default Gateway der Fritzbox.
Dann hast du nur einmal NAT an der Stelle, wo's sein muss, nämlich am Ausgang.
Die, der Uplink-Port zur Fritzbox,
den stell ich quasi dann auf die Geschwindigkeit ein, die mein Internetanschluss hat.
Also sprich, äh, 400 runter, 40 ab.
Braucht man für die, das braucht man für die Warteschlange, weil man wirklich QoS machen will.
Ja, und so dann, dann funktioniert das auch, ja.
Bring ich schon 125 Leute am Start.
5 Minuten nachdem ich, oder wie lang?
Ja, 15 Minuten nachdem ich Stream gestartet hab.
Das ist massiv.
Pock.
Ich hab übrigens letztens noch nen Subscriber vergessen, fällt mir gerade auf.
Und zwar, ich hab letztens vergessen, ich weiß gar nicht, ob er da ist,
ich muss grad mal Streamlabs aufmachen.
Und zwar, ich hab vergessen, den, ähm,
haben wir den Febe, Febe 2, Febe 2, für zwei Monate ist er schon dabei, ich weiß.
Ich weiß nicht, ob er da ist.
Also ich will's mir nicht vorwerfen lassen, dass ich Leute übersehe.
Und, ähm, ein, und vor 17 Stunden, da war ich definitiv im Bett und hab geschlafen.
Ähm, der Cube 0, der Cube Zero ist auch am Start.
Nice.
Huge Brain heute.
Wir starten heute mit Brain schon ein bisschen größer als normal.
Keine Amazon Prime Werbung.
Welche Amazon Prime Werbung?
What? Amazon Prime?
Ja, mach ich später.
Jetzt muss ich erstmal eine Weile online bleiben.
Pock.
Empfiehlt mir da eigentlich YouTube wieder für komische Dinger.
Was geht ja noch?
Die YouTube Empfehlungen hier gehen ja noch irgendwie, die sind noch relativ neutral.
Sag euch Leute, die YouTube Empfehlungen, was sind das da oben?
Bin ich eingeloggt mit irgendwas?
Ich muss euch mal kurz ausmachen, ich hab keine Ahnung, mit was ich da eingeloggt bin.
Warum, warum bin ich da eingeloggt?
MonkaS?
Lol, ich kann's euch zeigen, mit was ich eingeloggt bin.
Mit meinem Fake, mit meiner Fake E-Mail Adresse, die ich letztens erstellt habe.
Ich hab doch letztens eine Fake E-Mail Adresse gestellt, um einen Versandtracker zu testen.
Gleich, das ist halt, das ist halt so diese typische Google Geschichte.
Du machst eine Sache, ne, du machst eine Sache und bist sofort auf allen Plattformen connected und und sonst was.
Vorgestern.
Lustig.
So, wisst ihr was wir jetzt machen?
Jetzt hier, Settings.
History.
Clear.
Letzten sieben Tage.
Alles.
Alles. Bam.
Jetzt mal zu, jetzt mal auf.
Und nu bin ich nicht mehr eingeloggt.
Alter.
Warum bin ich hier?
YouTube, was ist da los?
Google, was ist da los?
Warum bin ich noch eingeloggt, obwohl ich die History gelöscht hab?
Was ist das?
Was, Chrome Log, was zum Teufel ist Chrome Login?
Ihh.
Was ist das?
Wo kommt das her? Warum ist das standardmäßig an?
Alter, die sind hartnäckig.
Die sind wirklich hartnäckig.
Okay.
Sign out.
Bam.
Reload.
Ah.
Jetzt ist weg.
Jetzt ist alles wieder weg.
Okay, nice.
Perfekt.
Es ist schlimmer als gedacht.
Ryzen 3000 Boost Umfrage.
Eigentlich, eigentlich, eigentlich müssen wir den Aura gucken wieder.
Hallo?
Den Aura, den Aura können wir nachher gucken.
Ähm.
Anschauen.
Na gut, wenn ihr sagt, dass wir das jetzt anschauen müssen, müssen wir das jetzt anschauen.
Da muss ich aber erstmal die Ärzte ausmachen.
Sonst, sonst hören wir vom Aura nichts.
Okay, gucken wir uns mal an, was der Aura zu sagen hat.
Hallo zusammen und herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video.
Auf dieses Video haben sehr viele von euch gewartet, denn heute schauen wir uns die Ergebnisse meiner Ryzen 3000 Boost Umfrage an.
Ich hab in den letzten zwei bis drei Tagen extrem viel Zeit damit...
Ich hab, ich hab schon einen 1080p Bildschirm, aber Leute, ich würd schon sagen, dass wir 4K gucken, oder?
Wir gucken 4K.
Es bringt zwar nix, aber einfach das Gefühl, 4K zu gucken, das ist einfach das Gefühl,
es bringt zwar nix, aber einfach das Gefühl, 4K zu gucken, das ist schon nice.
Damit verbracht, die ganzen Daten auszuwerten, es war unfassbar viel, dementsprechend auch sehr...
Außerdem sieht der Aura auch gleich schärfer aus auf 4K, ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Eigentlich sollte das keinen Unterschied machen, aber der sieht schärfer aus.
Gleich bessere Bitrate.
Stört dich dieses riesige UI nicht, wenn du Chrome im Vollbild hast?
Nö.
Wie viel was ich daraus ziehen konnte?
Viel was ich daraus ziehen konnte, das heißt, kommt jetzt ein bisschen später, als ich eigentlich wollte.
Ich hab, das sag ich auch im Voraus schon mal, auch schon mit AMD über diese Daten gesprochen,
weil es natürlich, ich sag mal, nicht so gut aussieht für AMD.
Und ich will der AMD-Gegenüber auch offen sein, denn es geht ja nicht darum, AMD fertig zu machen,
sondern es geht darum, quasi dieses Problem zu lösen.
Und wenn AMD aus diesen Daten auch was ziehen kann, dann ist das gut, keine Sorge,
da werden keine persönlichen Daten weitergegeben, sondern...
Da werden sie eben wieder vorwerfen, dass er voll der krasse AMD-Hater ist.
Das werfen eben die ganzen Fanboys eh immer vor.
Dabei hat der Ryzen im letzten, oder im einem letzten Team, so übelst gelobt.
Es wurde lediglich weitergegeben, was für eine CPU auf welchem Board mit welchem Takt lief.
Und da können keine persönlichen Daten irgendwie nachvollzogen werden,
deswegen, das sind die einzigen Daten, die ich weitergegeben hab.
Keine Kommentare, keine Accounts, E-Mail-Adressen, nichts in der Hinsicht wurde weitergegeben,
bevor jetzt wieder irgendjemand einen auf Datenschützer macht.
Wer macht 2019 noch auf Datenschützer?
Asus ROG?
Zum Thema ROG, ne?
Ich hab ja seit vier Jahren oder so so eine Asus ROG-Kappe.
Ähm, mal auf der, von wann war das? Von irgendeiner ESL-Veranstaltung in Köln war das, genau.
Und ich hab jetzt letztens Asus gefragt, ob sie mir nicht einfach mal eine neue Kappe geben könnten,
weil die geht langsam kaputt.
Haben sie gesagt, machen sie.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie zwei Monate her, ich hab immer noch keine Kappe.
Was mach ich denn jetzt?
Ich krieg immer weniger Haare, und wenn ich Sonnenbrand hab, ist Asus dran schuld.
ESC von ESS und die damit verbundene Soundqualität von der Konkurrenz ab.
Die ROG Pugio ist dabei die Waffe in eurer Hand für beste Präzision beim Zocken,
und sieht durch die RGB-Beleuchtung mit Aura Sync-Support dabei einfach doch unheimlich gut aus.
Ombronschalter mit einer Lebensdauer von 50 Millionen Klicks,
sowie einem Sensor mit 7200 DPI bilden dabei die Basis für die beidhändigen...
Nice!
Huge Sellout.
Für alle COD-Fans da draußen kann ich die Strix Flare Black Ops 4 Edition empfehlen.
Apropos Sellout, jetzt wo der Aura gerade Sellout macht.
Ich mach demnächst auch Sellout wahrscheinlich.
Für Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon Breakpoint.
Hat mich heute nämlich jemand angeschrieben per Mail, anscheinend haben die irgendwie so einen Live-Ticker,
wer wieder aktiv wird auf YouTube oder so, keine Ahnung.
Da müssen wir uns übrigens gleich noch mal ein Gameplay von angucken, was ihr dazu sagt.
Ich finde das sieht okay aus, aber das war's dann auch.
Genau, Breakpoint, da sind die gleichen, also mit denen hab ich schon mal was gemacht.
Und das gibt halt ordentlich, ordentlich Money deswegen.
Für ordentlich Money mach ich auch Sellout für alles Mögliche.
Kein Ding.
Kein Problem.
Für die viel angepasste Beleuchtung machen diese Tastatur wirklich einzigartig.
Die Strix Flare gibt es alternativ natürlich auch im gewohnten ARG Design
und durch das austauschbare Logo-Badge und Aura-Sync...
Für Money auf FaceCams, ey, für Money mach ich alles, aber das kommt immer auf die Bezahlung an, ja.
...euren individuellen Wünschen anpassen.
Euer Peripherie-Kit könnt ihr dann mit dem ARG Sheath Mousepad perfekt abrunden.
Bevor wir loslegen, ich werd auch gleich zu der Umfrage an sich noch mal ein bisschen was sagen,
schauen wir uns erstmal kurz den Marktanteil an, um so ein bisschen eine Übersicht über meine Umfrage
und die Ergebnisse zu bekommen.
Wir hatten insgesamt 2726 Einträge, das war Sonntagabend.
Mittlerweile sind es über 3000, aber ich musste natürlich...
Die hat, ach, jetzt kapier ich's, eine Umfrage gewacht.
Auf wie viel die Ryzen-CPUs boosten bei den Leuten?
An einem gewissen Punkt einfach quasi die Umfrage beenden,
beziehungsweise mir die Daten ziehen und mit diesen Daten auch arbeiten.
Und ich wollte auch ehrlich gesagt nicht zu viel Zeit lassen,
dass da zu viel Zeit vergeht, weil das gibt natürlich auch gewissen Herstellern,
sag ich mal, die Möglichkeit darauf zu reagieren.
Das Ganze möchte ich natürlich vermeiden, dass die Umfrage so real und nachvollziehbar wie möglich bleibt.
Wenn wir uns das Ganze anschauen, dann sehen wir, der größte Marktanteil ist aktuell mit 40% der 3700 X.
Ja gut, das wollte ich nicht.
Erfolgt von 3900 X mit 26%.
Wir haben uns ja mal aus Spaß einen Rechner zusammengestellt im Stream,
wo ich mir überlegt habe, ob ich mir nicht einen Ryzen Streaming-Rechner kaufen soll.
Allerdings habe ich dann gesagt, das ist eigentlich total bescheuert.
Wozu, ne?
Und ich glaube, da haben wir auch den genommen, den 3700 X.
Oder wenn 3800...
Nee, wir haben den 3700 X, glaube ich, damals auch eingeplant,
weil ordentlich Kerne, ordentlich Takt und alles andere darüber und darunter
war preisleistungsmäßig nicht viel besser, schlechter, als dass ich das gelohnt hätte.
Dem 3600 X gefolgt mit 21%.
Danach kommt mit 7% der 3600 X und nur mit 6% der 3800 X.
Das war eigentlich abzusehen, weil natürlich der 3800 X jetzt nicht wirklich die CPU ist, die Sinn macht.
Also kann ich auch nicht empfehlen.
Dementsprechend war das ungefähr abzusehen.
Aber es ist sehr cool, dass wir zumindest mal 3700 X, 3900 X und 3600 X haben extrem viele Ergebnisse.
Beim 3700 X über 1000, dementsprechend sind die Ergebnisse dann auch gut nachzuvollziehen.
Da haben viele mitgemacht, das finde ich auch sehr glaubwürdig.
Ich habe auch sehr viel Zeit damit verbracht, einfach nur die ganzen Kommentare zu lesen und das auch abzugleichen,
weil viele waren sich zum Beispiel nicht sicher, welche AG-Serversionen sie verwenden,
haben dann aber in die Kommentare hingeschrieben, BIOS-Version, F4 oder was auch immer.
Dann habe ich auf der Hersteller Website extra nochmal nachgeschaut, was das für eine Version war, habe das dann abgeglichen.
Also es waren sehr viele Ergebnisse, wo ich dann nochmal was quasi nacheditiert habe.
Ich habe viele Screenshots angehängt, alles angeschaut, war sehr, sehr viel Arbeit.
Aber ich wollte natürlich auch sicher sein, dass die Ergebnisse so zuverlässig wie möglich sind.
Einige Kommentare, die drin waren, auf die möchte ich mal kurz eingehen.
Zum Beispiel hatte ich jemanden dabei, der gesagt hat, okay, ich hatte eine krasse Wasserkühlung mit einem Chiller.
Leute, habt ihr was dagegen? Wenn wir die Comments überspringen und uns die Ergebnisse angucken?
Steht auf 1,25 Speed, nee, das hört sich beknackt an.
Überskippen, okay.
Individuell verwendeten Mainboard. Ganz so einfach ist die Sache leider nicht.
Das muss man ganz klar sagen, weil es ist nicht unbedingt Mainboard abhängig, es ist auch AG-Ser abhängig
und dann dazu auch noch SMU abhängig.
SMU ist also sowas wie zum Beispiel die Management Engine bei Intel.
Das ist nochmal so ein Teil, der auch mitgeflasht wird, wenn man zum Beispiel das BIOS flasht.
Und es kommt tatsächlich eben auch vor, dass man die gleiche AG-Ser-Version hat, aber unterschiedliche SMU-Versionen.
Und das Ganze macht es einfach unfassbar kompliziert, aber dann ist das Ergebnis, dass man auch mit einem Mainboard,
das zum Beispiel über Hardware unboxed, das X570A aus Extreme sehr gut boostet,
hier in der Umfrage trotzdem viele Probleme hat und das schauen wir uns dann gleich auch noch an.
Und da muss man sich natürlich fragen, wer ist hier der Schuldige?
Und ich muss sagen, es sind sowohl Mainboard-Hersteller als auch AMD definitiv schuld an diesem ganzen Chaos.
Erstmal haben wir das Problem, dass AMD kein Referenz-Board hat.
Das bedeutet, AMD hat kein Board, wo wir sagen können, okay, wir gehen in den Laden kaufen
und da wissen wir definitiv, jede Zirklung funktioniert darauf.
Es ist ja so, dass AMD quasi Hilfe gibt den Bordherstellern, aber die Bordhersteller
letztendlich alleine dastehen, wenn sie ihr Board designen.
Und so sagen es zum Beispiel auch die Bordhersteller zu mir, die sagen dann,
okay, wir kriegen zwar Feedback und Hilfe von AMD, aber oft weiß AMD auch nicht so genau, was da los ist.
Und dann kommt zum Beispiel AMD und schaut sich das bei Asus zum Beispiel an
und lässt sich selbst Workshops geben, um über die eigene CPU zu lernen.
Und es ist einfach ein unfassbares Chaos, was da hinter den Kulissen herrscht.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Und da muss man einfach sagen, sowohl die Mainboard-Hersteller als auch AMD sind da einfach, ich sag mal, schuld.
AMD müsste da besser kontrollieren, müsste gegebenenfalls ein Referenz-Board entwickeln,
auf dem sie sagen, okay, in diesem Zustand läuft alles, daran könnt ihr euch orientieren.
Aber es gibt wahrscheinlich AMD nicht hin, was zu entwickeln, wo alles drauf läuft.
Und auf Basis davon könnt ihr euer eigenes Board entwickeln.
Aber das ist nicht der Fall, sondern wir haben kein Board, auf dem wir sicher sagen können, hier funktioniert es oder hier funktioniert es nicht.
Also die Sache ist leider nicht ganz so einfach.
Kommen wir jetzt endlich zur Auswertung.
Natürlich wollte ich vorher diese Sachen klarstellen, das ist einfach wichtig, bevor wir über die Ergebnisse reden,
dass ihr wisst, wie meine Ansichten dazu sind, dass es natürlich auch kritisch zu betrachten ist, so eine ganze öffentliche Umfrage.
Ich weiß, in 53600, wir hatten 568 Ergebnisse, die ich als korrekt erachtet habe.
Bei jeder CPU habe ich so 3, 4, 5 Ergebnisse aussortieren müssen, die halt irgendwelche Troll-Ergebnisse waren.
Aber ja, da reden wir von 0,5 bis 1%, das hat keinen großen Einfluss.
Und jetzt seht ihr vor euch ein Histogramm.
Das bedeutet, wir haben hier eine Häufigkeitsverteilung.
Ihr seht in der Mitte diese einzelnen Balken und die einzelnen Balken beschreiben einfach, wie häufig ein gewisser Takt erreicht wurde.
Hier reden wir natürlich über den maximal erreichten Single-Core-Takt im Cinebench R15.
Also zum Beispiel die größte Säule ist bei 4200 Megahertz, wir haben 245 Ergebnisse, die den korrekten Boost von 4,2 Gigahertz erreicht haben.
Also nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe, ja.
Nur, dass ich das jetzt verstehe.
Also sprich, oder ihr könnt aber sagen, wie ihr das verstanden habt.
Sprich, ich habe eine Umfrage gemacht, wo die Leute quasi sagen konnten, was ihren Ryzen 5 3600, was der für einen Boost-Takt erreicht.
Das heißt, es haben 31 Leute quasi submitted, dass der 4025 Megahertz erreicht.
Und es haben 245 submitted, dass der 4200 erreicht.
Und ist jetzt 4200, ist das jetzt der offizielle, gibt es da überhaupt einen offiziellen Boost irgendwie?
Oder sagen die einfach nur, wir boosten so viel wie geht?
Okay, 4200 ist offiziell, aha.
Na gut, wenn 4200 offiziell ist, ist es aber schon ganz schön kacke, dass sagen wir mal die Hälfte unter dem offiziellen Boost ist, oder?
Das wäre ganz schön fail.
Der Toaster hat Twitch Prime subscribt.
Nice, danke schön.
Das ist natürlich sehr schön zu sehen.
Und wenn wir jetzt einfach mal nach links und rechts schauen, wir sehen, es gibt nur ganz wenige CPUs, die über dem Boost liegen.
Also zum Beispiel 11 Ergebnisse bei 4025 und so weiter.
Nach unten natürlich das gleiche Thema.
Wir haben auch einige Ergebnisse, die deutlich drunter liegen.
4100, 4125 MHz.
Und jetzt seht ihr links und rechts zwei Striche.
Also minus zwei Sigma und plus zwei Sigma.
Wenn man so ein Histogramm hier erstellt, das ist eigentlich extrem wichtig.
Das macht man vor allem auch, wenn man jetzt Produkte herstellt.
Also bei einer CNC-Fräse zum Beispiel.
Das ist wirklich für high IQ Leute geeignet.
Enttragen und kann dann zum Beispiel sehr gut sehen, wie ist so die Zuverlässigkeit bei der Produktion.
Und man kann auch Messfehler sehr gut ausgrenzen.
Und man sagt bei so einer Analyse eigentlich, wenn man so ein Histogramm erstellt, dass alles außerhalb von minus zwei und plus zwei Sigma als Fehler anzusehen ist.
Und in unserem Fall seht ihr zum Beispiel, wir haben da 4025 ganz links.
Und jetzt seht ihr links oben beim Diagramm die ausgerechneten Werte.
Ihr seht minus zwei Sigma ist bei 4015 MHz und plus zwei Sigma ist bei 4300 MHz.
Also alles, was über 4300 liegt.
Bei 4025, nicht bei 4015, oder?
Oder ist es?
Wird hier als Messfehler deklariert.
Das sind Ergebnisse, die wir nicht betrachten.
Und alles, was unter 4015 MHz liegt, wird in dieser Analyse auch nicht betrachtet.
Das bedeutet, wenn wir minus zwei und plus zwei Sigma betrachten, dann sind 542 der 568 Ergebnisse innerhalb dieses Bereiches.
Das entspricht ungefähr 95 Prozent.
Und die anderen 5 Prozent, also minus 2,5 Prozent plus 2,5 Prozent, die werden quasi als Messfehler aussortiert.
Das ist einfach unfassbar wichtig.
Ansonsten ruiniert man sich diese Ergebnisse, weil man eben sagen kann, wenn hier einer bei 4400 MHz liegt.
Also das heißt im Endeffekt, dass man die gar zu extremen Bullshit-Ergebnisse aussortiert.
Wenn jetzt irgendwie einer nur einen Boosttakt von, keine Ahnung, 2 MHz hat oder so, wird das sonst das ganze Bild versauen.
Wenn ich das richtig verstehe.
Deswegen schneidet er das einfach ab.
Sagt er, was quasi weiter als so abweicht, fliegt weg und weiter als so abweicht, fliegt weg.
Dann ist das einfach extrem unwahrscheinlich und größtenfalls dann entweder ein Eintrag oder ein Messfehler.
Deswegen werden solche Werte dann nicht betrachtet.
Wenn wir jetzt das Ergebnis betrachten, dann liegen 270 der 542 CPUs innerhalb der Spezifikation.
Das heißt, die haben den Boost erreicht von den beworbenen 4,2 GHz oder lagen drüber.
Alles andere, also 50%, die Hälfte der CPUs hat den angegebenen Boost nicht erreicht.
Da habe ich doch gerade gesagt, da habe ich das richtig interpretiert.
Das ist doch Fail, oder?
Also ich meine, wenn AMD sagt, 4200 ist Boost und die CPU kriegt das nicht gebacken, dann sollen sie nicht 4200 draufschreiben.
Auch ganz klar sagen, wir reden hier ja von dem maximalen Single-Core-Takt, den wir irgendwann mal bei einem Benchmark gesehen haben.
Und wenn ihr selber mitgemacht habt, dann wisst ihr, diese 4,2 GHz, die wahrscheinlich mal erreicht wurden,
die liegen dann nicht durchgehend an, sondern die CPU geht dann wieder runter auf 4100, 4125.
Das heißt, wir haben hier ja nur den oberen krassen Fall betrachtet.
In der Realität kann man von diesen Ergebnissen eigentlich nochmal 50 bis 75 MHz abziehen.
Das heißt, das Ganze ist eigentlich noch ein bisschen kritischer, als das wir sehen.
Aber beim Ryzen 5 3600 sieht es nicht so schlimm aus.
Da liegen immerhin 50%, also jede zweite CPU erreicht den Boost-Takt.
Das ist schon mal ein gutes Ergebnis.
Jetzt wird das Ganze noch ein bisschen interessanter, denn jetzt schauen wir uns den 3600X an.
Also jetzt wird es ja immer anspruchsvoller.
Die CPUs, die wir jetzt betrachten, haben alle immer mehr Takt angegeben.
Dementsprechend wird es auch immer schwieriger für die CPU, diesen Takt natürlich zu erreichen.
3600X, 190 Ergebnisse plus Sigma bei 4497 minus 2 Sigma bei 4143.
Das heißt, wir hatten ein paar Ergebnisse, die links und rechts davon waren, die wir natürlich nicht betrachten.
Wir haben 180 von 190 Ergebnissen innerhalb der Minus und plus 2 Sigma.
Das heißt, nur 10 Ergebnisse werden quasi als Messtoleranz angesehen.
Wenn wir uns jetzt aber anschauen, wie viele CPUs tatsächlich den maximalen Boost erreicht haben,
dann sind das gerade mal 17 aus 180.
Jetzt nur, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
AMD sagt zum Beispiel, maximal Boost ist 4200.
Allerdings ist maximal Boost nicht garantiert nach dem Motto,
wenn nur ein Kern ausgelastet ist, dann kriegst du auch 4200.
Sondern das ist, wenn noch genug Spielraum bei der Temperatur ist.
Oder?
Also mal angenommen, ich passiv kühle das Ding jetzt,
dann müsste ich mich auch nicht wundern, wenn der gar nicht boostet.
Ich muss einfach Turbo-Taste am PC drücken.
Das sind nur 9,4 Prozent der CPUs haben die 4,4 GHz Boost kurz gesehen oder waren drüber.
Drüber waren nur drei.
Einer war bei 4425, einer war bei 4450.
Alle anderen, glatte 90 Prozent der CPUs, haben den Boost nicht erreicht.
Kommen wir jetzt zum 3700X.
Wahrscheinlich das wichtigste Ergebnis, weil wir haben hier über 1000 Ergebnisse.
1087 insgesamt, minus 2 Sigma bei 4211 MHz, plus 2 Sigma bei 4477 MHz.
Da ist wieder der größte Teil runter.
Auf der linken Seite, also unterhalb 2 Sigma, da haben wir viele einzelne Ergebnisse.
Zum Beispiel 2 bei 4050, 3 bei 4075.
Da kann man sich sicher sein, dass irgendwas nicht passt.
Wenn die CPU nur so hochboostet, dann ist es entweder ein BIOS-Bug
oder irgendwas anderes ist mit der Konfiguration vom Setup nicht richtig.
Deswegen ist es auch korrekt, dass diese Ergebnisse gestrichen werden durch die Gasverteilung.
Wir haben dennoch insgesamt 1036 aus 1087 Ergebnisse, die wir als gültig betrachten.
Wenn wir jetzt den Boost anschauen, dann haben wir 153 aus 1039 CPUs, die mindestens den...
Ach so, Kingwall, jetzt kapiere ich das.
Es geht gar nicht so sehr um die technische Seite, die scheiße wäre,
sondern dass quasi AMD draufschreibt 4400 und die Leute dann halt, sagen wir mal,
den Standardkühler draufmachen und sich beschweren, dass es nicht 4400 ist
und das Ding zurückschicken oder so.
Was natürlich für Case King oder wo er arbeitet, ziemlich sackt,
wenn die Leute laufend CPUs zurückschicken.
Also im Prinzip müsste AMD sagen, maximal Boost 4400,
nur wenn ihr da, keine Ahnung, Stickstoff draufmacht, so nach dem Motto.
...Boost erreicht haben von 4,4 Gigahertz.
Wir haben 19 CPUs, die drüber waren, also 4,425 zum Beispiel, 4,45.
Und dann haben wir, wenn wir es noch ein bisschen stretchen,
den plus zwei Sigma hätten vielleicht noch mal fünf dazu.
Aber das macht den Braten nicht fett, dann hätten wir 158 aus 1039.
Also es ist immer noch eine sehr kleine Anzahl.
Das ist kein Hitzeproblem, das heißt, die Dinger schaffen einfach,
egal wie gut gekühlt, den Boost nicht, obwohl es AMD draufschreibt, oder wie?
Ja, das ist natürlich bescheuert.
Das ist natürlich begnackt.
Dr. Pons fragt, du hast mal irgendwie zu E3 Window Manager
oder so Linux-mäßig geswitcht, wie heißt das Programm?
E3 Window Manager? E3WM heißt das? Oder was meinste?
Wir haben insgesamt 85% der CPUs, die den Boost nicht erreichen.
Und jetzt sagt ihr vielleicht, okay, aber 415 Ergebnisse erreichen 4,375
und kann man da nicht einfach aufrunden? Nein, kann man nicht.
Definitiv nicht, weil es ja auch oft so ist, dass die CPUs einen Boost,
weil es ja oft auch so ist, dass die CPUs eine BCLK von 99,8 MHz verwenden.
Ach so, ja, vor allem ja. Workstation.
Das heißt, ihr habt da 4,366 MHz in der Realität
und wir haben hier nur den maximalen Single-Core-Boost.
Das heißt, alle, die jetzt zum Beispiel 4,375 angegeben haben
und das als Maximum erreicht haben,
haben während dem Benchmark meistens nur 4,3, vielleicht 4,325.
Das heißt, man kann hier nicht einfach aufrunden.
So einfach ist das Problem nicht zu lösen.
Kommen wir zum 3800X.
In diese CPU hatte ich eigentlich mit die meiste Hoffnung,
weil der 3800X laut AMD ja quasi ein höher gebinder 3700X ist.
Also der müsste eigentlich den Booster eher erreichen.
Und weil es eben kein 12-Kanner ist, sondern nur ein 8-Kanner,
ist die Leistungsaufnahme nicht ganz so hoch.
Das heißt, bei dieser CPU hatte ich quasi die größte Hoffnung,
dass der Boost erreicht wird.
Wir hatten 159 Ergebnisse.
Neun Ergebnisse sind durch Minus 2 und Plus 2 Sigma rausgefallen.
Und wenn wir uns jetzt anschauen, wie viele im Boost liegen,
dann waren es 26,7%, die bei 4,5 oder drüber lagen.
Wir hatten relativ viele, die dann 4,525 und 4,55 hatten.
Also das war eigentlich ganz gut zu sehen.
Und dann sehen wir auch 48 Ergebnisse bei 4,475.
Also wieder das gleiche Spiel, wo der Boost quasi knapp verfehlt wurde maximal.
Aber eben während der Benchmark dann ja trotzdem der Boost noch weiter abfällt.
Aber auch hier quasi drei Viertel der CPUs hat den Boost nicht erreicht.
Kommen wir jetzt zum 3900X.
Und aus meiner Sicht auch mit so die wichtigste CPU,
weil die ja auch so den krass höchsten Boost hat in der Werbung.
Und natürlich in Hinblick auf den kommenden 3950X.
Wie ist das Stand mit der ASP-Seite?
Meinst du die Fiverr-Geschichte oder meinst du den Versandtracker?
Der noch mal 100 MHz mehr können soll,
stehe ich dem Ganzen natürlich relativ kritisch gegenüber, sage ich mal,
was den beworbenen Boost betrifft.
Fiverr sage ich gleich was.
Wir haben bei 3900X insgesamt 722 Ergebnisse.
Minus 2 Sigma bei 4238, plus 2 bei 4711.
Wir hatten darüber fast kein Ergebnis, was rausgefiltert wurde.
Aber darunter einige.
Also ihr seht, wir hatten 425 bei 4100.
Da kann man sich natürlich sicher sein, dass da bei dem 3900X auf jeden Fall was nicht stimmen kann.
685 der 722 Ergebnisse waren innerhalb der Minus und plus 2 Sigma.
Und dann haben wir 3 Follower.
Und wenn wir jetzt mal anschauen, wie viele CPUs den Boost tatsächlich schaffen,
dann ist das wirklich vernichtend.
Wir haben hier glatte 5%.
38 aus 674 CPUs haben den Boost erreicht.
Wenn man das mal anschaut, wir hatten 13 bei 4600.
Und dann ein paar drüber, 4625.
38 von 674.
Und 90% der CPUs erreichen den Boost nicht.
Und das muss man sich erst mal auf der Zunge zergehen lassen.
Das heißt eigentlich keine.
Also 95% der CPUs erreichen den Boost nicht.
Das ist eine krasse Nummer.
Das ist deutlich schlimmer, als ich dachte.
Und damit kann ich auch ganz klar bestätigen, dass es nicht ein Problem ist, was nur bei mir existiert, wie es am Anfang hieß.
Weil bei meinem allerersten Video, das sich ja veröffentlicht hat, als die Ryzen CPUs auf den Markt gekommen sind,
da habe ich ja das Thema quasi als Erster angesprochen.
Da kam Feedback von vielen anderen, die gesagt haben,
warum bist du der Einzige, der darüber berichtet?
Kein anderer Reviewer hat es...
Das heißt, nur, dass ich es richtig verstehe, das kann ich auch nicht irgendwie erzwingen oder so.
Also wenn die CPU nicht will, dann will sie nicht.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht irgendwie sagen, so nach dem Motto, ich mache jetzt irgendwie, ich sage jetzt mal doof,
irgendwie Multiplikator höher, irgendwas höher, Multi-Core-Einhalt, etwas höher
und sage, hey CPU, mach diesen Takt scheiß drauf, ob du abkackst.
Also im Prinzip, wenn AMD das Internet irgendwie so eingestellt hat, dass das nicht geht, dann geht das nicht.
Am Start behauptet oder gesagt, bei dir muss irgendwas falsch gelaufen sein.
So war so der Tonus.
Nicht nur von mir, also nicht nur von anderen Reviewern, sondern auch von AMD selbst, sage ich mal.
Und das hat mir natürlich auch selber zu denken gegeben, habe dann quasi daran gezweifelt, geschaut,
habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht.
Ich würde sagen, definitiv nicht.
Wir haben hier definitiv ein Problem.
Und jetzt, wo wir die 3900X Ergebnisse kennen und ihr wahrscheinlich sagen werdet,
aber das hängt alles vom Mainboard ab, schauen wir jetzt mal eine Mainboard spezifische Analyse an
und da schauen wir jetzt den 3900X an auf dem X570 AORUS Xtreme.
Das war das Board, was bei Hardware Unboxed am besten abgeschnitten hat
und wo er gesagt hat, okay, hier erreicht eigentlich jeder Kern den Boost beim 3800X.
Wir haben jetzt hier den 3900X, weil ich hier die meisten Ergebnisse mit diesem Board hatte.
Ja, da muss man ganz klar sagen, wenn wir uns das anschauen,
wir haben fünf CPUs aus 27, die das mit diesem Board schaffen.
Das heißt 22 CPUs haben es auch hier nicht geschafft.
Also ihr seht, es liegt teilweise deutlich drunter.
Man kann hier nicht so einfach sagen, dass wenn man das Board kauft, dass plötzlich alle Probleme gelöst sind.
Das Gleiche noch mal nur als zweites Board, weil ich damit auch mit so die meisten Ergebnisse hatte,
war das X570 AORUS Lite, 37 Ergebnisse,
paar lagen drunter, wurden quasi aussortiert durch das Minus 2 Sigma.
Wir sehen zwei CPUs aus 37 erreichen den Boost und 35 liegen drunter.
Ja, weiß nicht, was soll ich dazu sagen?
Dass es sagt.
Es ist ein sehr komplexes Thema.
Piss dich, AMD.
Ich glaube, da werden wir noch lange dran zu knabbern haben, AMD auch.
Aber trotzdem sind die Reisen-CPUs nicht übel.
Ich hoffe, ich habe das Video nicht zu lange gestretched, weil ja,
ich wollte natürlich so viel Daten wie möglich präsentieren.
Ich habe wirklich alles präsentieren können.
Wenn das nicht geht, was draufsteht, ist immer kacke.
Wir haben natürlich auch noch viele Analysen, die wir ausziehen können, was Mainboard betrifft,
was AG-Serverwiesungen betrifft usw.
Wäre für dieses Video viel zu viel.
Um das noch mal kurz zusammenzufassen.
Aktuell beste CPU, was die beworbenen Boost-Frequenz betrifft, ist der 3600.
4,2 GHz Boost ist eben auch nicht so schwer zu erreichen.
Wenn wir alles andere betrachten, gerade den 3900X mit 95%, die den Boost nicht schaffen,
dann ist das wirklich viel, viel, viel schlimmer, als ich dachte.
Ich dachte, so vielleicht 50% schaffen das, aber 95% nicht.
Das sehe ich tatsächlich als großes Problem an.
Und ich glaube auch nicht, dass es so einfach zu lösen ist.
Weil ich habe mit allen Mainboard-Herstellern gesprochen über diese Ergebnisse.
Mit allen habe ich telefoniert.
Alle haben mir gegenüber bestätigt, dass es bei denen intern auch so aussieht
und sie keine Lösung haben, um dieses Problem zu lösen.
Haben auch mit AMD gesprochen und AMD aktuell quasi auch keine Lösung dafür besitzt.
Das Ganze wird übrigens von einem Statement von Chamino, der bei Asus arbeitet, untermauert.
Denk ich euch unten rein, könnt ihr euch auch mal durchlesen.
Ich glaube, dass die CPUs in der Fertigung einfach nicht so gut sind, wie das, was beworben wird.
Was ich dann natürlich auch direkt wieder sagen muss, die CPUs sind extrem gut.
Versteht mich nicht wieder falsch.
Der Ryzen 3000 ist nach wie vor eine unfassbar gute CPU.
Und ich rate jedem dazu, wenn ihr euch ein neues Setup holt, schaut euch die CPU an.
Und bevor ihr z.B. einen 9500K kauft, gerade wenn ihr Creator seid,
überlegt euch das und kauft euch vielleicht doch einen Ryzen.
Das sage ich ganz deutlich, weil die CPUs extrem gut sind.
Gerade der 3600, was Preis-Performance angeht, eine unschlagbare CPU.
Ich rate euch dazu, kauft die CPUs.
Aber seid nicht enttäuscht, wenn der Boost am Ende nicht funktioniert.
Man kommt nicht zu mir an bei Casing und sagt, ich möchte die CPU zurückgeben, weil der Boost nicht funktioniert.
Ich habe es euch gesagt.
Das wollte ich nur loswerden.
Jetzt muss man eigentlich immer nach Casing schreiben.
Ich möchte die CPU zurückgeben.
Lasst mich gerne wissen in den Kommentaren, was ihr davon haltet.
Wenn ihr spezifische Sachen haben wollt, gerne unten rein.
Ich schaue mir das gerne an.
Ich nehme mir die Zeit dazu, noch mehr Analysen zu machen.
Wir machen gerne Follow-Up-Videos zu diesem Thema.
Aber ich glaube, dass die CPUs diesen Boost niemals schaffen werden,
weil sie einfach in der Fertigung nicht so gut sind, wie AMD es gerne hätte für den Boost.
Was auch nie nötig war.
Man hätte einfach den Boost nie so bewerben dürfen und sollen.
Einfach nur, um Investoren zufrieden zu stellen.
Oder weil man sagt, vielleicht kaufen die mehr, wenn ich 4,6 GHz draufschreibe.
Aber die hätten das einfach so machen sollen.
Da hätten sie mal was von deutschen Internetprovidern lernen können.
Die sollten einfach nicht draufschreiben, Boosttakt 4400.
Die sollten das einfach machen wie DSL-Anbieter.
Sollen draufschreiben, Boosttakt bis zu 4400.
Alles wäre gut gewesen.
Die CPUs sind so gut.
Man hätte sich das Leben unnötig schwer machen müssen.
So, reicht jetzt aber. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Tschau.
Also ich muss echt sagen, der Auer, der Bauer, der macht immer sehr nice Videos.
Die sind auch immer so, wie sagt man, so fundiert irgendwie.
So durchdacht.
Also ich gucke die Videos wirklich gerne.
Ich meine, mich interessiert nicht jedes Thema.
Aber jedes Mal, wenn ich ein Video gucke, sind die wirklich immer gut gemacht.
Und auch vor allem, was mir an den Videos gut gefällt ist,
der stellt sich halt hin und erzählt halt, um was es geht.
Und macht nicht irgendwie erstmal 30 Cuts, wo er über den Bildschirm jumpt oder so.
Der stellt sich hin, zeigt das, erklärt das auch gut, hat auch Ahnung, wovon er erzählt.
Also das ist wirklich schon nice.
Der Auer.
Der Acht Auer, genau.
Ich finde die Videos gut.
Ah ja, ja.
Also, Fiverr. Jetzt kann ich was zu Fiverr erzählen.
Fiverr.
Also ich habe, ich habe 11, ich habe 11.
Okay.
RIP Fiverr.
Ah, jetzt geht es, okay.
Also ich habe 11 wahrscheinlich, ich denke mal, zum größten Teil indische,
also für alle, die es nicht mitgekriegt haben,
zum größten Teil indische.NET Core ASP.NET Programmierer beauftragt,
was zu programmieren.
Und was sie programmieren sollten, ist so eine kleine Twitch Chat,
so eine kleine Twitch Chat App.
Also haben wir selbst schon gebastelt hier im Stream, ist nicht kompliziert.
Um ungefähr 200 Zeilen Code inklusive HTML.
Wolltest du nicht ein Video machen?
Es gibt ja noch nichts.
So und ich muss mich da jetzt erstmal einloggen, dass ich es euch zeigen kann.
Dazu muss ich euch mal ausschalten, weil ich mich natürlich
mit meiner privaten E-Mail Adresse registriert habe,
anstatt mich mal mit meiner Büssiness E-Mail zu registrieren,
was aber auch Absicht gewesen ist, denn ich will ja nicht,
dass die mich irgendwie enttarnen oder so.
Moment Leute, ich logge mich mal kurz ein.
Video Capture ausmachen.
KeyPass aufmachen auf der anderen Seite.
Geht gleich weiter.
So, Fiverr.
Login.
Alter, das Login funktioniert nicht.
Ey, das ist jetzt Fiverr.
Das ist jetzt nicht dein Ernst.
Fiverr ist übrigens die größte Bullshit-Seite ever,
weil die alle Furzlern Captures gelöst haben möchte von mir.
Das geht, das braucht alle 5 Minuten kommt das auf Fiverr.
Ohne Scheiß, alle 5 Minuten.
Und dann geht das manchmal weg.
Und dann kommt das nächste Capture.
Und wenn das weggeht, kommt das nächste Capture.
Und jetzt darf ich Traffic Lights auswählen.
Das ist nicht Uplog.
Oh, ich hatte Uplog gerade ausgeschaltet.
Ach, jetzt hat es noch nicht mal eingeloggt.
Alter, Fiverr.
Bra.
Tippt.
Richtig.
Fiverr.
Sign in.
Passwort.
Never.
Okay.
Ich bin Signed in.
Ich Noob habe es jetzt zwar nicht im anonymen Tab gemacht,
aber ist draufgeschissen.
Also, ich blende euch mal wieder ein.
Also es fällt schon mal auf, ich heiße Peter.
Wie wir das aus dem In the Scammer-Video kennen.
Ich musste mich da mit irgendeinem Fake-Namen anmelden.
Ich konnte mich ja wohl kaum so nennen wie mein YouTube-Channel oder wie sonst was.
Also, Peter ist am Start.
Und jetzt passt mal auf die Ausbeute, Leute.
Ihr seht, ich habe ganz schön viel beauftragt.
Jetzt gucken wir uns mal die Orders an.
Von 11 Orders haben sieben cancelled.
Ja, deswegen habe ich so viel Guthaben.
Weil die Leute gecancelt haben.
Die haben sich alle nicht getraut, das zu machen.
Sieben hatten keinen Bock.
Ey Leute, also die cancelled kann ich euch ja mal zeigen.
Das ist echt lustig.
Also, wir fangen mal mit dem...
Ich weiß nicht, wir fangen jetzt einfach mal oben an.
Also.
Ja, genau.
Der hat überhaupt nicht gecheckt, was ich haben wollte.
Also, ich habe ihm das hier geschrieben.
Okay.
Also, richtig.
So haben wir das nämlich auch gemacht.
So.
Dann will ich, dass das Ganze ohne Twitch-Login funktioniert.
Und dass ich auch nicht immer den Channel und Usernamen konfigurieren kann.
Es ist nichts Schwieriges.
Hört sich jetzt vielleicht kompliziert an.
Ich kann euch gleich nochmal meine Anwendung zeigen.
Das sind wie gesagt 200 Zeilen.
Dass die Chat-Messages sollen gespeichert werden, da ich es neu starten kann.
Und ich hätte gerne einen Knopf, dass ich einzelne Nachrichten löschen kann.
So, und jetzt kommt die Antwort von ihm.
Die war auch huge.
So, er hat hier geschrieben.
So.
So, und jetzt habe ich gesagt.
Okay.
Ich habe dir doch geschrieben, was ich will.
Was willst du genau wissen?
Erklär mir doch was, was du nicht verstehst.
Und dann hat er irgendwie sowas drauf geschrieben.
Ich konnte nicht herausfinden, was das ist, weshalb ich dein Projekt nicht machen kann.
Du kannst zu irgendeinem anderen Seller gehen.
Danke.
Was?
Okay.
Ja, und da habe ich halt gesagt.
Ich habe cancelt.
Ich will denen ja nicht das Leben schwer machen.
Ich will denen ja nicht das Leben wirklich schwer machen.
Ich habe immer, wenn die gefragt haben, cancel, habe ich immer zugestimmt.
Wie gesagt, ich will denen weder die Bewertung versauen, noch will ich denen das Leben schwer machen,
oder die irgendwie abfacken oder so.
Der wollte nicht, ja.
Meine Beschreibung ist auch schlecht, ja.
Sackt richtig.
Die Beschreibung.
Ich habe mir im Nachhinein nochmal darüber Gedanken gemacht, über die Beschreibung.
Die Beschreibung ist eigentlich ziemlich gut, wie sie ist, weil sie ist nicht hundertprozentig klar.
Ich hätte das theoretisch hier drunter noch besser beschreiben können.
Allerdings, wenn man Programmierer ist und quasi, es gehört ein bisschen mit zur Aufgabe,
dass man einen Brain dafür hat, so ungefähr zu erfassen, was die Leute haben wollen.
Den anderen habe ich sogar noch ein bisschen genauer erklärt.
Ja, hier 16,20 Euro.
Der andere hat 4,70 Euro gehabt, ja.
Dass man dann nachfragt, das ist okay, ja.
Aus der Beschreibung erkennt man es eigentlich schon ganz gut.
Den anderen habe ich dann im Nachhinein nochmal genauer erklärt, so nach dem Motto,
ich will eine Anwendung haben, die alle Chat-Nachrichten mitschneidet aus einem gewissen Channel
und einfach filtert, ob mal ein Usernamen drin vorkommt.
Was machst du gerade beruflich? Mach mal Ausruf, Zeichen, Beruf.
So, was haben wir als nächstes gehabt? Den hier hatten wir als nächstes.
Der war schon für 20 Euro am Start.
Ach, der hatte auch keinen Bock, ja.
Obwohl er auf seiner Seite schreibt, I will do ASP.NET MVC Core 2 Web, was auch immer.
So, und das hier macht er alles.
Backend.NET Core Frontend JavaScript.
Also genau das, genau, warum geht Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf nicht?
Ist der Nightbot kaputt?
Ach ne, weil oben drüber schon einer Ausrufe, Zeichen, Beruf gemacht hat.
So, und der war auch geil.
Sagt immer, hello, I'm not work on Chatbot applications.
Okay, cancel.
Da hab ich gesagt, okay, dann feel free to cancel.
Da hat er halt gesagt, ja, okay, das würde seine Ratings daunen können.
Okay, cancel ich halt.
Okay, next.
Jetzt kommt als nächstes kommt der Full-Stack-Development on.NET.
Hi Max.
I need to tell you this, but can you please cancel this order?
Das war das einzige, der hatte keinen Bock.
Na gut, wer will auch für 11,43 Euro arbeiten, ja?
Wer hat da auch Bock drauf, ja?
Ich hätte auch keinen Bock drauf, für 11,43 zu arbeiten.
Amit hatte keinen Bock.
Ähm, obwohl er auch hier genau geschrieben hat, wenn man sich das mal anguckt.
Äh, new web app from scratch.
Der hat, das passt, also, ich hab mir ja wirklich Leute rausgesucht,
die, ähm, die es auch so beschrieben haben,
dass sie das können und machen, was ich haben will, ja?
Sind das alles, na ja, ich glaube, wenn du einen Programmierer in Deutschland suchst,
der macht für 9,59 Euro nicht mehr seine IDE auf.
So, den haben wir als nächstes.
Develop any kind of ASP.NET MVC or Core application.
Any kind, ja?
Hope you enjoying good health.
Thanks for contacting, but I'm not available, so kindly cancel your order.
Was ich witzig finde bei dem ist, auf der Projektseite steht,
trust me, we are always available for you.
Und das erste, was ich von ihm höre ist, sorry, but I'm not available.
Huge.
Aber gut, ich mein, das war auch der billigste, 6,66 Euro.
Ey, Leute, die Sache ist die, die Sache ist ja die.
4,80 Euro, Alter.
Ich mein, I will develop a complete web application in this package.
4,80 Euro.
Ich hab mir das ja nicht ausgedacht.
Ich hab ja schon, ich hab ja extra welche gesucht, die das genau reingeschrieben haben.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass ich mir das aus...
Also ich hab die ja nicht gezwungen dafür, das da reinzusetzen oder so.
So, next.
Weil die anderen zwei zeige ich euch heute noch nicht, da gucken wir uns erst die Ergebnisse an.
Und die anderen vier, weil die anderen vier hab ich noch Hoffnung, ja.
Ah, nächster.
I will do bootstrap related work.
Da hab ich ihm noch mal reingepastet, was ich haben will.
Hi, why are you directly order?
Ey, die haben alle eigentlich ziemlich gute Bewertung.
Da wollte ich erst zurückschreiben.
Ja gut.
Weil es auf deiner Seite steht.
Good, cancel.
Nächster.
Die letzten zwei waren auch ganz cool.
Die wollten mehr money haben.
Der Steff, der Steff ist gut.
Ich weiß nicht, wo der Steff herkommt, aber der hat Ahnung.
Was ist das, Griechenland?
Nee, wo ist das?
Wo kommt der, wo ist das?
Osteuropa, Mazedonien, ja.
Also der hatte gefühlt, gefühlt, hatte der die meiste Ahnung, ja.
This is possible, access Twitch API.
Da hab ich ihm gesagt, nee, ich will das Ganze nicht über die Twitch API haben, aber
ich habe irgendwo gehört, dass der Twitch Chat auch IRC hat.
Und ich habe sogar mal ein paar Beispiele gefunden, wie das IRC Chat funktioniert, aber
ich bin nicht gut genug dafür im Programmieren, um das selbst zu programmieren, ja.
When do you expect to finish?
No hurry, what do you think?
Well, I can start tomorrow.
Pass, hast mehr Zeit.
Ich habe ihm gesagt, ich spende ihm sogar noch mal 11 Euro, wenn das rechtzeitig schafft, ja.
Und dann hat er gesagt, how much budget?
Da hab ich schon gedacht, Alter, jetzt will er mich jebaiten.
Hab ich einfach mal hingeschrieben, 50 Euro.
Obwohl das Ding für 11 abgeschlossen ist oder so.
Aber okay, 50 Euro.
Sorry, wartest du nicht?
At least 700 Euro.
Jetzt geht's ab.
Also einfach mal einen GIG reingesetzt für 11,43 und dann 700 Euro haben wollen.
Das ist Next Level.
Und ich habe nur drauf geantwortet, are you ready to pay the price?
No.
Ist das überhaupt überlaubt über Fiverr?
Keine Ahnung.
So, der nächste.
Einen haben wir noch, einen haben wir noch.
Der wollte auch mehr Geld, glaube ich.
Hello, thanks for order.
Okay, es wäre besser, wenn ich ihn vorher kontaktiert hätte.
Sorry, I can't do this task.
Für 20,96 Euro.
Was fändest du an angemessener Preis?
Keine Ahnung.
Also wenn man das ordentlich macht, wenn man das ordentlich macht und ich sag mal, du brauchst so eins, zwei,
sagen wir mal drei Stunden, drei Stunden für wenn du das ordentlich machst, so immer 150 Euro.
Also für 150 Euro würde ich mir überlegen.
Moment, du kannst das mit 100 Euro Stundenlohn ja nicht so rechnen.
Ich meine, ich muss ja erstmal auf die Seite gehen, ich muss den Krams erstellen,
ich muss Steuern drauf bezahlen.
Letztendlich, wenn du selbstständiger Programmierer bist, ist es ein bisschen was anderes.
Da musst du dich schon ordentlich bezahlen lassen.
Also für 150 Euro ist okay.
Kannst du kurz erklären, was dein Nattyp bedeutet? Also strikt offen.
Ich sag's jetzt nochmal, hier im Stream.
Ich hab's ganz oft in Kommentaren geschrieben.
Nattyp.
Ich hab's ganz oft in Kommentaren geschrieben und zwar haben wir mal ein schönes Setting,
schönes Bildchen für Nattyp.
Hier, da.
Dieses Wort ist eine komplette Erfindung der Konsolenhersteller.
Es gibt keinen Nattyp.
Sowas existiert nicht.
Das einzige, was es gibt, ist Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Alles andere ist irgendwie ganz merkwürdige Microsoft-Sony-Logik.
Es gibt in der Netzwerktechnik nichts, was sich Nattyp nennt.
Entweder leitest du die Ports weiter, die gebraucht werden,
oder du leitest die Ports nicht weiter, die gebraucht werden. Fertig.
Also Nattyp gibt es nicht.
Ja, es gibt so Tabellen, wo Leute dann gesagt haben nach dem Motto, ey,
was verstehen denn die Konsolenhersteller darunter?
Aber es gibt sowas in der Netzwerktechnik nicht. Sowas wie Nattyp.
Vielleicht meinen die double Nattyp.
Nein, was die meinen ist, du hast Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Das meinen die damit. Nix anderes.
Muss übrigens jetzt nochmal in die Settings gehen.
Da muss ich in meine History, Clear Broser-Data und sagen Clear.
Perfekt.
Nattyp gibt es doch auch bei Kot auf dem PC.
Okay, ich korrigiere, es war keine reine Erfindung der Konsolenhersteller.
Es war eine Erfindung von Konsolen-Game-Herstellern und Konsolen-Herstellern.
Wie sieht es mit den Active-Bar-Fiver aus?
Ach so, was hat das Ganze jetzt mit den Linux Mint zu tun?
Noch absolut gar nichts, noch null.
Eigentlich hatte ich vor, um mit den neuen Linux Mint Varianten anzugucken,
die rausgekommen ist.
Cleaner Desktop ist nice, oder?
Eigentlich sah der Desktop immer so aus.
Sort.
Wie sortet man hier nochmal?
Sieht doch schon gar nicht mehr so wild aus.
Also was die damit halt einfach meinen, du hast deine Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Wenn du Ports weiterleiten willst, gehst dir für einen Router, suchst dir raus,
was du Spiel für Ports brauchst und leitest die weiter.
Fertig.
Wie gesagt, das mit offen und geschlossen ist Bullshit der Spieler-Entwickler.
Sowas gibt es nicht.
Aber was wollen wir eigentlich ausprobieren?
LMDE.
Debian Edition.
Was ist denn das Neue? Das Neue war glaube ich Tina, ne?
Ja.
Tina, die haben immer Grillnamen.
Und 6. August, Tina wollen wir haben.
Und Hannah Montana, die lassen uns nichts machen.
Oder vielleicht nachher noch.
Also wenn ihr Probleme habt, dass irgendwas von wegen Nattyp drin steht, ganz einfach.
Ihr googelt einfach, welche Ports ihr für das jeweilige Spiel oder für die jeweilige Konsole
meinetwegen weiterleiten müsst.
Tragt es in eurem Router ein und gut ist.
Max, eines deiner letzten Videos hat mich voll geil auf BFPC3 gemacht.
Ich hoffe das bald...oh ja, hoffe ich auch.
Und ich würde den PC nicht auf Exposed Host stellen, auf keinen Fall.
Benutzt du eigentlich Firefox? Klar.
Ich benutze fast alle Browser.
Außer Opera Gaming Edition.
Oder wie dieses Ding heißt.
Das verwende ich nicht.
Ok, was interessiert uns denn am neuen Linux Mint?
Cinnamon Edition featuring Cinnamon, Mate, XFCE, LMDE.
Was für einen Desktop wollen wir da ausprobieren?
Wir können doch alle drei ausprobieren.
Also, Mate ist ein GNOME 2 Fork.
XFCE ist was eigenes.
Auch auf GTK Basis.
Und Cinnamon ist, glaube ich, eine GNOME 3 Geschichte.
Ich glaube Cinnamon ist Standard.
Ok, 64-Bit Download.
Mit Download und Ctina jetzt.
Von? Gibt's haben die auch einen German Mirror?
Ja, FHA, die sind immer schnell.
Das flutscht.
Schau mal an hier.
Ah, 12MB die Sekunde, kann ich mitleben.
Hey Max, ich bin glücklicher Besitzer einer DS Lite Leitung.
Debated.
Aber die Frage kommt tatsächlich öfters.
Mit DS Lite, um es jetzt nochmal ausdrücklich zu sagen.
Mit DS Lite hat man gelitten, wenn man daheim was laufen lassen will.
Funktioniert nicht.
Es sei denn, alle connecten sich bei LPv6.
Was aber die wenigsten machen werden.
Hast du eine 250er Leitung?
Nee, aktuell habe ich nur eine 100 Down, 5 ab.
Aber demnächst habe ich wie gesagt 40 ab, 400 down.
Dünn DNS bringt dir überhaupt nichts bei DS Lite, gar nichts.
Um nicht zu sagen Null.
Weil Dünn DNS sorgt ja nicht dafür, dass die Leute auf einmal durch das Natt durchkommen vom Provider.
Hamachi, Hamachi funktioniert ja.
VPN Geschichten funktionieren auch.
Likans, ja.
Ich meine Zuschauer ja auch.
Übrigens, Prime.
Wollte ich nochmal anmerken.
Primer im Chat.
Der huge Sellout, der kommt nachher.
SSH Tunnel dürfte auch gehen, ja SSH Tunnel geht auch.
Die möglichen Sachen, die sie irgendwie schaffen von außen, von innen nach außen eine Verbindung aufzubauen, wo man dann von außen nach innen kann, funktionieren.
Ist DS Lite das, was Unity Media macht?
Genau.
Also nur um das nochmal kurz zu erklären, wie das Ganze funktioniert.
DS Lite.
Mal gucken, ob es da schöne Bilder dazu gibt, da muss ich sie nicht selbst malen.
Was für einen Prozessor würdest du empfehlen für aktuelle Games?
AMD oder Intel?
Also aktuell würde ich mir einen Ryzen kaufen.
Würde ich mir entweder...
Wahrscheinlich für einen Ryzen...
3700X war das, glaube ich, oder dann 3800X würde ich mir kaufen.
Wir hatten letztes Jahr mal im Stream sowas zusammengestellt.
Okay.
DS Lite ist nicht so eine gute Idee zu suchen.
Du bist echt leid.
Ja, das ist doch ein ganz schönes Bild.
Ja, das ist ein schönes Bild.
Also, was uns das ganze Bild hier sagen möchte, ist folgendes.
Ist da vielleicht noch ein schöneres Bild für das da, ha?
Das ist zu übertrieben.
Das Bild ist aber ganz gut hier.
Also, was DS Lite bzw. DS Lite mit, muss man dazu sagen, auch Carrier Crate...
Natt nennt sich das Ganze, ja.
Was die machen, ist folgendes.
Oder warum machen die das überhaupt?
Unity Media hat zu wenige IPv4-Adressen, zumindest in der Vergangenheit.
Mittlerweile haben sie anscheinend irgendwo auf dem Schwarzmarkt welche erstanden oder so.
Weiß ich nicht.
Zumindest Unity Media hat zu wenig IPv6-Adressen.
Ey, ich mach Sinn.
Zu wenig IPv4-Adressen.
Big Brain.
Deswegen, was macht Unity Media?
Unity Media muss ja ihren Leuten IPv4 zur Verfügung stellen.
Ohne IPv4 funktioniert das Internet 2019 leider nur zur Hälfte.
So, das Problem ist jetzt, dass sie zu wenig IPv4-Adressen haben für jeden Kunde,
um dem eine IPv4-Adresse zu geben.
Deswegen sagt Unity Media, gut, dann kriegen unsere Kunden einfach nur noch IPv6-Adressen.
Und mehrere Kunden teilen sich eine externe IPv4-Adresse.
So, das ist der Gedanke dahinter, hinter DualStack Lite.
DualStack bedeutet ja eigentlich nur, du kriegst eine IPv4 und eine IPv6-Adresse.
Und DualStack Lite bedeutet im Endeffekt, du kriegst nur eine vollwertige IPv6-Adresse,
dafür eine private IPv4-Adresse, die über IPv6 getunnelt wird.
Also, funktioniert folgendermaßen.
Du brauchst ja von deinem Rechner Zugriff aufs Internet.
Sowohl IPv4 als auch IPv6.
Manche Sachen gibt es schlicht, da kann man doch nicht in IPv6.
Oder vielleicht hat man ein Gerät, was kein IPv6 kann.
So, und IPv6 ist kein Problem.
Hast du eine IPv6-Adresse, hat der Rechner im Internet, den du aufrufen willst,
so wie Google zum Beispiel, eine IPv6-Adresse, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Dann geht das direkt von deinem Host zum Server im Internet und vom Server im Internet zu deinem Host.
Überhaupt kein Problem.
Hier ist eine Firewall dazwischen, dass das nicht so ohne weiteres geht.
Aber das ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Bei IPv4 sieht es mittlerweile schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Du teilst dir nämlich eine IPv4-Adresse mit mehreren Kunden bei Unity Media.
So, und hier ist Unity Media an der Stelle.
Unity Media macht für dich nochmal natt.
Also sprich, das ist ganz, ganz grob gesagt.
Du hast eine private IPv4-Adresse, also sowas wie 10.10.10.10 oder sowas.
Und die wird quasi über deine IPv6-Leitung zu Unity Media geschickt.
Also IPv4 wird verpackt in IPv6, wird zu Unity Media verschickt.
In Unity Media wird das wieder ausgepackt.
Dort teilst du dir mit, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 150, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie viele es wirklich sind.
Mit 150 Kunden ist rein aus der Luft gegriffen die Zahl.
Kunden eine Public IPv4-Adresse.
Hier wird das übersetzt.
Dann geht's von Unity Media zum Server, stellvertretend für dich.
Der Server zurück zu Unity Media.
Unity Media guckt nach, wer hat die Anfrage ursprünglich gestellt.
Packt das Ganze wieder ein in IPv6.
Schickst du dir zurück, dann wird das Ganze wieder ausgepackt.
Wobei, nee, bis zum Router geht das Ganze.
Hier wird das Ganze wieder ausgepackt.
Und sein Host kriegt es auf seiner privaten IPv4-Adresse.
Hat man das verstanden?
Ich mein, das war jetzt ein bisschen Big Brain.
So, und das Problem ist bei der ganzen Geschichte, wenn man vom Internet per IPv6 zugreifen möchte, kein Problem.
Geht direkt.
Wenn jetzt irgendjemand vom Internet aus, wenn er jetzt sagt, hey, ich würde gerne einen Minecraft-Server laufen lassen bei mir.
Dann hast du das Problem, da müsste ja jemand aus dem Internet auf deinen Server kommen.
Dein Server steht nicht nur hinter deinem Router, sondern steht hinter einem Carrier Create NAT, also sprich hinter einem Provider NAT bei Unity Media.
Und Unity Media gibt dir garantiert nicht die Zugangsdaten für ihren Router, um dort Port Forwarding auf deine private IPv4-Adresse einzurichten.
Da müssten wir echt mal bei Unity Media anrufen und fragen, wie sieht das aus, kriege ich Zugriff auf euren NAT-Router?
Ich würde mir gerne ein paar Port Weiterleitungen einrichten.
Mal gucken, wahrscheinlich ist dieser Typ an der Hotline, da sagt er nur, Alter, was willst du?
Ich habe keine Ahnung von eurem Sprechstil.
Peppy, who are you? Twitch Prime, Dankeschön, Pog.
Ja, das ist Dulce, der kleine Carrier Create NAT.
Also, der übelste Bullshit ist das.
Das ist übelster Müll, warte mal kurz.
Max Mutors.
Ja, so funktioniert das mit Unity Media.
Also, es ist Crap.
Deswegen kannst du ja auch keinen Minecraft-Server laufen lassen.
Nicht so ohne weiteres.
Du kannst natürlich, was geht ist, du könntest einen weiteren Tunnel bauen.
Du könntest einen weiteren Tunnel bauen.
Angenommen, du hättest hier im Internet...
Achso, übrigens mit dieser Geschichte, weil irgendjemand was von wegen NAT-Typ geschrieben hat.
Also, nachdem du hier nie die Möglichkeit hast, Ports weiterzuleiten, wirst du auch nie auf deiner Konsole angezeigt bekommen, dass du irgendwie einen offenen NAT-Typ oder so hast.
Auch wenn es einen NAT-Typ an sich überhaupt nicht gibt.
So, und was du machen kannst ist...
Angenommen, also das erste, was du machen kannst, ist Unity Media auf den Sack gehen.
Das habe ich damals auch gemacht.
Ich bin in ein paar Wochen auf Twitter öffentlich auf den Keks gegangen.
Ich meine, ich habe den Vorteil, dass ich, glaube ich, irgendwie 22.000 oder so Follower habe auf Twitter.
Da ist es natürlich in gewisse, ein bisschen mehr Druck, sagen wir mal, dahinter, wie wenn da andere vielleicht schreiben auf Twitter.
Das heißt, Unity Media hat mich dann umgestellt.
Und was du machen kannst ist, natürlich kann man von hier nach außen einen Tunnel aufbauen.
Also mal angenommen, du würdest dir hier einen Server mieten im Internet und du baust einen Tunnel auf von deinem Host zu diesem IPv4-Server.
Und dieser Server hat eine publik IPv4-Adresse, was er ja haben muss, sonst wird es ihn gar nicht erreichen.
Dann kannst du einen Tunnel aufbauen von da dahin und kannst dann wiederum sagen, alles, was auf diesen Server connectet, geht durch den Tunnel dahin.
Das ist aber übelst krass durch die Brust ins Auge.
Weil dann gehen deine Taten quasi in einem Tunnel über einen Carrier-Create-Nut, IPv6-Tunnel, IPv6, entpacken zu dir, also das geht aber, das geht.
Das muss auch gar nicht komplizierter sein, das muss kein OpenVPN oder sowas sein, da reicht eine SSH-Verbindung.
SSH, von da nach da, SSH-G, Port aufmachen, Listen und hier redirect, geht, gar kein Problem.
Das ist aber wirklich eine ganz hässliche Lösung.
Wäre es nicht möglich, dass Unity Media zu so einem Vertrag noch eins bis zwei Port-Forwardings dazu gibt?
Möglich wäre das, ja.
Gibt es? Richtig, es gibt keinen Nattyp.
Es gibt nur Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Das ist in dem Fall ziemlich binary, ja.
Wir sind nicht in dieser Art und Weise, sondern entweder Ports weitergeleitet oder Ports nicht weitergeleitet.
Wie DS Lite mit der Vodafone-Übernahme abgeschafft ist, glaube ich nicht, die haben nicht genug IPv4-Adressen.
Oder haben so etwas auch andere Anbieter?
Ehrlich gesagt, ich kenne es nur von Unity Media, aber ich würde wundern, wenn das andere nicht auch machen würden.
Das ist die einzige Variante, die du machen kannst.
Du musst deinen Kunden IPv4 geben und wenn du selbst zu wenig Public-IP-Adressen hast, hast du gelitten.
Hey, wo bloß? Hey Max, ESP-866 und ESP-32 könnten per W-Line gecrashed und übernommen werden.
Ich will zumindest mal abschauen.
Interessant.
Nice.
Muss man dazu im W-Line sein oder reicht das, wenn man in der Nähe ist?
Bildschirmarbeiter, hast du das mal durchgelesen?
Master Fiddy, willkommen im Stream.
624, äh doch, doch, doch.
Also in der Regel ist es immer viel einfacher, IPv6, also Public, ähm, warte mal.
Nee, nee, umgedreht, umgedreht, geht. Also du kannst ziemlich gut, ähm, sagen wir mal eine Public, eine Public IPv6-Adresse mappen auf eine interne IPv4-Adresse.
Ausgehend ist nicht möglich.
Ausgehend, also was du nicht machen kannst ist, ähm, außer mit irgendeinem Proxy, mit komischen Settings, aber in der Regel kann man sagen, es ist nicht möglich, mit einem Host, der eine IPv4-Adresse hat, auf IPv6-Internet zuzugreifen, geht nicht.
Egal, was man für komische Router-Rewrite-Dinger macht.
Liegt einfach daran, weil ein Host mit IPv4 auch nur DNS-IPv4-Auflösungen macht.
Unter anderem.
Erhöht sich durch solch eine Geschichte der Ping ins Spiel, na klar.
Klar.
Du hast hier eine Zwischenstufe drinnen, die wahrscheinlich auch ordentlich prumpt unter der Last, weil das ist ja nicht, da ist ja nicht nur einer, der da drüber geht.
Es wird alles doppelt und dreifach ein- und ausgepackt. Da hast du, da hast du mit Sicherheit einen höheren Ping.
Es hält sich jetzt in Grenzen. Es wird jetzt nicht so sein, dass du auf einmal, dass du, keine Ahnung, normalerweise einen 6er-Ping hast und danach einen 50er-Ping.
Aber ein paar Millisekunden wird das schon bringen, wird das schon ausmachen.
Der Schoko-Klaus sagt hallo. Moin Schoko-Klaus.
Machst du eigentlich DevOps auf der Arbeit, ja? Kann man so nennen. Das ist ja der neueste Trend, dass man das DevOps nennt.
So, gut, jetzt installieren wir uns die Lux Mint.
Nattyp ist, ob man per UPNP Ports freigeben kann oder ob man Punch-Holen muss.
Das Problem ist, dass so Geschiss wie Kot und sowas nicht Punch-Holt.
Dazu bräuchten sie ja den Server in der Mitte. Und du müsstest, wenn du Punch-Holen würdest, was wahrscheinlich kein Mensch überhaupt versteht und was ich jetzt erzähle,
dann bräuchte du diesen ganzen Geschiss nicht von wegen Ports weiterleiten für die Kontrolle.
Skype macht das ja auch so. Skype macht das ja auch so für Voice. Skype-Kommunikation ist P2P, allerdings mit einem Vermittlungs-Server, der die Nat-Ports aufmacht.
Es funktioniert schon, aber da haben Sony und Microsoft und Call of Duty Geschiss keinen Bock drauf.
Okay, feiern wir. Starten. Geht's.
Was ist das Maximum, was Telekom bei dir anbietet bzw. wieso willst du bei Unity Media bleiben?
Ich war bei der Telekom. Ich hatte die ganze Zeit einen Unity Media Anschluss und einen Telekom Anschluss. Beides.
Und das war mir jetzt mit der Zeit ehrlich gesagt einfach zu teuer.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt gesagt, okay, Unity Media bietet das bessere Gesamtpaket bei mir.
Und sie haben mir garantiert, dass ich mein IPv4 behalte, ansonsten flame ich die halt wieder auf Twitter zwei Wochen am Stück.
Unity Media hat 440 ab, Telekom hätte maximal bei mir 250 dauernd, dafür 100 ab.
Dafür hat Unity Media das bessere Gesamtpaket, weil auch Fernseh dabei ist.
Ich brauche nämlich eh einen Kabelanschluss und das lohnt sich nicht, zwei Anschlüsse zu bezahlen.
Das ist deutlich billiger, wenn ich nur Unity Media nehme. Und was bei mir noch dazukommt, ist, dass bei mir die Telekom entgegen irgendwie allen anderen in Deutschland gefühlt weniger stabil war als Unity Media.
Okay, wir machen mal eine neue VM.
Custom.
Workstation.
Next. Linux.
Was haben wir runtergeladen?
Mint, ja das ist ein Ubuntu.
Sorry Leute, jetzt kommen die ganzen Ubuntu Aussprache Leute wieder.
Ubuntu ist das.
Ubuntu.
Weil die Leute immer drauf stehen, weil man den Kram besonders stylisch ausspricht.
Das ist Mint.
Eine CPU, drei Kerne, sind wir mal großzügig, machen wir mal drei Kerne.
Warte mal, wie viele Kerne habe ich?
Sechs Kerne habe ich, ne?
Sechs Kerne habe ich.
Fail. Früher, Leute, ich habe sechs Kerne. Früher konnte ich mir, von jeder aktuellen CPU, konnte ich hier runter beten, fast schon wie viel Cash da Kram hat.
Und heute überlege ich, wie viele Kerne meine eigene CPU hat. Das ist nicht Big Brain, das ist Small Brain.
Wo steht es überhaupt, wie viele Kerne man hat? Ach hier, sechs Cores.
Let's fail. Okay, dann reichen drei Kerne aus. 2G RAM reichen auch aus. Dat ist okay.
Alles, Create Virtual Disk 20G ist auch gut.
Finish. Okay.
Also, installieren wir mal das neue Linux Mint und gucken uns das Ganze an.
Einen Drucker brauchen wir nicht, eine Soundkarte lassen wir dran, USB Controller lassen wir...
USB Controller machen wir aus, weil lässt sich manchmal meine Maus oder mein Audiointerface crabben bei einer neuen VM.
Da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
So, ISO Image.
Download Linux Mint.
Schauen wir mal, wie das läuft.
Also unsere letzten zwei Tests, elementary hat mich ja sehr überzeugt, das letzte Mal von der Optik her.
MX Linux hat mir das letzte Mal überhaupt nicht so gefallen.
Lul bin auch gerade am Linux Mint installiert, nice.
Small Brain Emote, 3Head. Nee, 3Head ist eher ein Emote, wo einer von die Wand gerannt ist.
Oh!
Huge Sound Effects und Huge Auflösung.
Komm, wir scalen das Ganze mal. Wir sagen jetzt, wir kriegen das nochmal.
Restretch.
So.
Huge Auflösung auf jeden Fall schon mal hier.
Install.
Wie wäre es mit Gentoo testen?
Das können wir mal machen, da brauchen wir aber viel Zeit.
Wobei das meiste kompiliert relativ schnell.
Ich sehe es ja bei Maima und Jaro.
Alle Custom-Pakete musst du ja auch selbst kompilieren.
Bloß, dass halt fertige Skripte und so dabei sind.
Bisschen wie bei Gentoo eigentlich.
Das Kompilieren geht in der Regel relativ schnell.
Spielst du BFPC2 auf Origin oder auf Steam?
Auf Origin.
Sind die Server getrennt? Ich dachte, die Server sind nicht getrennt, oder?
Bad Company 2 Origin und Steam sollten doch die gleichen Server sein.
Ja, ja, wir testen ja irgendwann auch nochmal.
Hannah Montana Linoxer.
Okay, Englisch, ja.
Das ist der normale Ubuntu Installer.
Gea.
Germann.
No-Dead-Keys.
No-Dead-Keys sorgt dafür, dass hier Dings und Tilde und dieses Hütchen und das Zirkum-Flex,
wie sich das ja glaub ich nennt, dass das ordentlich funktioniert.
Continue.
Oh, ja, mach mal.
Bad Company 1 ist noch GameSpy.
Keine Ahnung, Bad Company 1 ist konsolenexklusiv, können wir da nicht spielen.
Noist.
Continue.
Berlin.
Username.
Okay, wer hat zuletzt gesubbt?
Wer hat zuletzt gesubbt?
Nein, wer zuletzt gesubbt hat, natürlich.
Das ist zu spät.
MSIT, danke schön für den Sub.
Oh, das ist zu spät jetzt.
Das war zwar Big Brain Fast Reaction Sub, aber das zählt jetzt nicht, wenn ich das gesagt
hab.
Wer hat denn jetzt davor gesubbt?
Peppi, who are you?
Okay, dann heißt unser Linux jetzt Peppi.
Peppi.
Lena, komm, dann machen wir das.
Komm, wir sind mal so.
Username ist MSIT und Computername ist Peppi, Passwort 123456.
Ich hoffe, ich kann mir das merken, weil mein Username ist sonst immer Test.
Machen wir es so.
Require my Passport.
Ja, continue.
So, lassen wir mal installieren.
Noch nicht September.
Stimmt, das wollte ich mal.
Was genau ist das eigentlich?
Während es installiert, guck mal, was ist eigentlich noch mal September gewesen?
123456 ist fair Passwort, ja?
Ich verstehe auch nicht, was mit denen los ist.
Okay, September.
Since September was introduced in 2017, okay.
Am dritten, heute geht es los.
Ab 1 Uhr PT.
1 Uhr PT ist 22 Uhr.
Also in dreieinhalb Stunden.
50% off tier 1 Subs.
Oh, da müsste ich ja eigentlich heute nach 22 Uhr noch mal on gehen.
50% off.
Himzudi, Dankeschön.
Fridge Prime.
Kann man die überhaupt tonaten?
Gute Frage.
Lesen wir mal.
Made on a web browser or your desktop app so you can support even more off.
Okay, das heißt im Endeffekt, du kannst deine Kohle einfach auf mehr Leute verteilen.
Ach ja, gut.
Ach, okay, guck mal, man kann sogar Subscription extenden für die Hälfte des Preises.
Das ist doch nice.
Also wer richtig feifett ist, der extendet natürlich jetzt.
Also wer clever ist, der wartet einfach noch bis morgen oder so mit dem Extenden.
Streamers continue to receive full value.
Ja, das ist nice.
Okay, im Prinzip ist das eigentlich nur, dass die Subs jetzt die Hälfte kosten.
Oder ein bisschen weniger als die Hälfte.
Gilt diesmal nur, wenn man nie Sub war?
Nee.
Sie haben doch eben gerade gesagt.
You can also continue your subscription for...
Ach so, if you have any active gift Subs.
Okay, das heißt, wenn man Twitch Prime Sub ist und zu einem normalen Sub wechselt,
kostet es quasi 50%.
Oder wenn man einen Gifted Sub hat und auf einen Sub wechselt.
Na gut, die wollen halt den Anreiz schaffen, dass die Leute eine Autoverlängerung für den Sub machen.
Okay, was gibt es sonst noch?
Custom Emotes.
Habt ihr eigentlich schon die ganzen Emotes gesehen, Leute, die wir hier haben?
Huge Emotes, ja.
Wir haben ganze vier Emotes von 14 oder so.
Hab ich schon drinne.
Ich muss mich morgen mal hinsetzen und noch ein paar Emotes mir aus den Fingern saugen, die man machen könnte.
Ich muss ja sagen, mein persönlicher Favorit ist tatsächlich der quasi Cup HD Wupp Cup.
Weil das hat keiner sonst.
Die haben alle den normalen Cup und wir haben den Wupp Cup.
Wubblul gibt es schon bei der Twitch TV.
Ja, ich weiß.
Ich hab Wubblul, hab ich auch mit minimalen Änderungen geklaut.
Wieso kein MonkaW, weil ich MonkaW nicht mag.
MonkaW, das gefällt mir nicht.
MonkaGiga ist nice, MonkaX ist nice, MonkaS ist nice, aber MonkaW mag ich nicht.
MonkaX, ihr könnt MonkaX machen zum Beispiel, das haben die wenigsten drin.
MonkaW mag ich nicht.
Wenn ich MonkaW brauche, also wenn ich einen haben will, der die Augen besonders groß macht, nämlich MonkaGiga.
Wann wird denn am Staubsauger gezockt?
Wir haben letztens Custom Program auf dem Staubsauger laufen lassen im Stream.
Ziggy Freud, Twitch Prime.
Nice, huge, big, big brain, Dankeschön.
Okay, was gibt's denn sonst noch?
Subscriber-Batch, Leute, ab nächsten Monat, ich sag's ja nur ungern, ab nächsten Monat brauche ich eine 3-Monat-Subscriber-Batch.
Geht ganz schön schnell, oder?
Zeit geht echt schnell rum.
Wo hast du die Stimme her für mein Memeport?
Das ist ein Text-to-Speech-Service, ein koreanischer oder japanischer Text-to-Speech-Service.
Ich weiß aber nicht mal, wie der Kram hieß.
Voice Texts, Japan oder so?
Da kannst du dir im Prinzip irgendwas reinschreiben und das liest das Ding vor.
Und ich hab's halt so eingebaut, dass man Text eingeben kann, er lädt das hoch und lädt sich dann die Datei runter und speichert sich's.
Weil sonst müsste ich jedes Mal hier eine halbe Minute warten, bis der was ausspricht.
Aber ich muss ja sagen, meine Lieblings-Voice-Geschichten hier im Memeport ist ja eindeutig die Kombination hier.
Das ist immer noch die beste Kombination.
Wen haben wir hier? Der Raptor. 3-1-1-2. Twitch Prime.
Der Durchschnitts-IQ ist heute ja schon so hoch. Dankeschön für den Zapp.
Wen haben wir sonst noch? Den Solomann.
Oder hab ich verguckt. Ah ne, der Solomann sagt nur Hallo. Hi Solomann.
Ok, mal gucken, ob Mint installiert hat.
PLEASE REMOVE INSTALLATION MEER.
Hab ich schon oder? Aber noch nicht.
Wie löscht man das eigentlich so?
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wie man das löscht, aber wir drücken jetzt einfach mal Enter.
Never.
So, jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, ob Linux Mint vor Ember Tools dabei hat.
Mal gucken, ob Linux Mint vor Ember Tools dabei hat.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Wow.
Sie haben anscheinend keine vor Ember Tools dabei.
Dann müssen wir erstmal vor Ember Tools installieren.
Huge Passport.
Rollenschinke Kuro.
Was war? Hat es irgendwie Geräusche gemacht?
Ach, du meinst hier das Ding.
So laut war das nicht.
Ok, wie hieß den Kram noch mal, den man vor Ember Tools installieren muss?
Kann es sein, dass die keine vor Ember Tools...
Nee, nicht vor Ember Tools, vor Ember Tools hieß das.
Vor Ember Tools? Nee, wie?
Guck mal, der Chat weiß es schon, der Chat weiß es schon wieder.
Desktop.
Genau, das war das.
Install.
Yes.
Ok.
Sag, erst die Tools selber und dann den Desktop. Nee, die wird dir witzig, weil wir das als Abhängigkeit mitbringen.
Sehr schön.
Ok, Linux Mint ist am Start mit ordentlicher Auflösung.
Ja, was testen wir denn? Was haben wir das letzte Mal getestet?
Genau, erstmal gucken, ob wir uns irgendwie zurechtfinden.
Was standardmäßig dabei?
Firefox, Terminal.
Firefox ist lahm wie immer.
Nee, Firefox braucht einfach ein bisschen länger, bis es startet meistens.
Firefox ist schnell.
Was haben wir für ein Terminal? Sieht ein bisschen aus wie ein Gnome Terminal.
Ist allerdings ein...
Was ist denn? Ein Gnome Terminal. Gnome Terminal ist auch mein Lieblingsterminal, passt.
Moin, der Provokateur, auch am Start.
Was haben wir für Standardschriften dabei? Haben wir da irgendwas Sinnvolles?
Moment, wo konnte man das nochmal einstellen?
General, wo war das nochmal mit den...
Wo gingen da nochmal die Schrifte an? Das war doch hier immer sonst.
Ah, Custom Font hier unten.
Haben wir sowas wie Roboto Hack oder so? Nee, haben wir nicht dabei.
Haben die das in den Hack?
Haben die Hack Font?
Haben die irgendwie sowas?
Fonts Hack.
Sehr gut.
Bester Font, den braucht man immer.
Hack Font.
Welche Formel nutzt du? Das ist Firewall Workstation.
So, und jetzt gucken wir mal, ob wir Hack auswählen können.
Hack, bester Font.
Da ist er.
Das gefällt mir schon mal gut, dass es schön durchdacht.
Kannst du den größer machen, den ganzen Mist?
Ja, das sieht doch jetzt nach einem ordentlichen Terminal aus hier.
Transparenz noch ausschalten, dann ist alles gut.
Okay, das sieht doch jetzt schon mal nach einem ordentlichen Terminal aus, das gefällt mir.
Das kann man verwenden auf jeden Fall.
Was ich auch ganz gut finde, dass die hier den ganzen Kram halbwegs an den richtigen Stellen haben,
weil es geht mir bei Ubuntu immer auf den Keks, wenn es auf einmal hier links ist.
Was ist dein Favorite MMO of all time? Dark Hatch of Camelot.
Not even close.
Beste.
Ich wollte dich nicht drücken gerade.
Dark Hatch of Camelot, beste.
Ich will für immer beste MMO bleiben, zumindest bei mir im Kopf.
Ja, aber damit kann man arbeiten, das ist doch schon mal ganz nice.
TMUX, ja auf jeden Fall.
Was haben wir denn eigentlich für einen Vim dabei?
Haben wir einen Vim dabei?
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Also install.
Die GTK Vim.
Den installiere ich bloß, weil dann auch die Clipboard Erweiterungen immer dabei sind.
TMUX und Hardtop brauchen wir.
Muss, ohne geht nicht.
Neo Vim Vim.
So ein großer Unterschied ist es doch gar nicht.
Die sind ein bisschen eingeschlafen bei Neo Vim.
Die ganzen Background-Task-Geschichten und so haben die jetzt im richtigen Vim auch.
Also die Neo Vim Leute sind ein bisschen eingeschlafen.
Eine SL brauchen wir nicht.
Okay, haben wir ASCII-Quarium?
Kein ASCII-Quarium, na gut.
Aber TMUX ist am Start, ist doch schon mal was.
TMUX ist am Start und Hardtop für Auslastung läuft auch.
Da sind auch schon die wichtigsten Sachen drauf.
Gefällt mir gut.
Man merkt einfach auch, dass ein Ubuntu drunter ist.
Ubuntu.
So, Google.
Gehen wir mal auf YouTube.
Oder was ist denn für eine default-Suche drinne hier?
Test.
IGIT, JAHU.
Ist das euer Ernst?
JAHU-Suche.
Wer verwendet denn sowas?
Wo stellt man den Kram mittlerweile ein?
Nee.
JAHU.
Wer, wer, wer macht denn sowas her?
Search.
Äh.
Ach du Scheiße, wo gehen das hin?
Die Google ist da gar nicht dabei.
Dann nehmen wir DuckDuckGo.
DuckDuckGo ist auch gut.
Ich bin, ich hab mich, wie geht das euch eigentlich?
Ähm.
So die letzten, so das letzte halbe Jahr oder so.
Ist mir aufgefallen, dass ich immer mehr bei DuckDuckGo lande.
Oftmals.
Subscriber.
Oh, das kann ich nicht aussprechen.
Konnte ich das das letzte Mal aussprechen?
Ice Freak?
Doch Ice Freak.
Klar kann ich das aussprechen.
LeadSpeak kein Problem für mich.
Easy.
DuckDuckGo ist ganz nice wegen den ihren Bangs.
Was ist, was ist denn ein Bang auf DuckDuckGo?
Das einzige was ich bei DuckDuckGo ein bisschen vermisse ist der Google Cache.
Allerdings Google Cache passt ja irgendwie nicht zusammen, ne?
Mit der anderen Suchmaschine.
Also ich muss sagen, ich vermeide Google nicht irgendwie wegen irgendwelchen Tracking-Kram.
Ähm, das ist natürlich auch legitim.
Achso, du kannst direkt auf Google suchen, ja.
Ich überlege mir bloß gerade, warum ich angefangen habe DuckDuckGo zu verwenden.
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr, was war denn der Grund?
Ich weiß nur noch, dass ich mit manchen Sachen auf Google überhaupt nicht zufrieden war.
Und wo ich dann festgestellt habe, DuckDuckGo funktioniert das viel besser.
Ich weiß es nicht mehr.
Oh, Dark Theme, ja.
Wo ist es?
Wo ist das Dark Theme?
Das brauchen wir.
Ganz wichtig.
Dark Theme.
Ah, das ist viel angenehmer.
Die dunkle Ente.
Ich weiß es ehrlich, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht sagen, ich weiß es nicht.
Kommen gleich wieder irgendwelche komischen Streaming, illegalen Streaming Seiten am Start,
wenn du hier auf DuckDuckGo suchst.
Ähm, ne, keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht mehr, was es war, aber ich weiß, dass mir irgendwas auf Google so auf den Keks gegangen ist,
dass ich mittlerweile oftmals DuckDuckGo verwende.
Gut, also, mal gucken, wie YouTube läuft, ob alles dabei ist, was man braucht für YouTube.
Ich meine, YouTube selbst ist ja mittlerweile rein HTML5.
Aber es sollte eigentlich ohne Probleme funktionieren.
Aber man weiß nie.
So sieht also die Startseite aus von YouTube, wenn man noch nie drauf war.
Trending.
Ach du Scheiße, was ist das denn, was da trendet, äh.
Meine Güte, alter YouTuber.
Ist da irgendwas drinne, was man überhaupt, ja, das kann man aufmachen.
Okay, funktioniert das Video?
Okay, erstmal schön, fett die Werbung natürlich.
Erstmal skippen, funktioniert, funktioniert.
So, funktioniert in HD, funktioniert in 4K, 4K ist in der VM immer eklig.
Sogar 4K funktioniert nice in der VM.
Was haben wir denn für eine Auslastung dabei?
Oh, sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
4K Video flüssig in der VM, ähm.
Und quasi nur ein CPU Kern komplett ausgelastet.
In der VM ist ja leider Video nicht, ähm, nicht GPU decoded, ja.
Das sackt.
Du kannst, du kannst in, du kannst eh nichts hardware beschleunigt decoden in der VM.
Das haben sie bis heute nicht hingekriegt.
Das ärgert mich auch ein bisschen, weil es müsste technisch möglich sein,
dass du, ähm, den, den H264-Decoder vorm Host verwendest,
wenn die da ein driver für bereitstellen würden.
Gibt's leider nicht.
So, gucken wir uns mal an, Battlefield, 60Hz.
Oh, schon ein bisschen mehr, schon ein bisschen mehr Auslastung.
Aber es läuft gut, es läuft wirklich okay.
IGIT, der Opera Gaming Browser.
Aber ganz schick, also es ist okay.
Ich meine, die CPU-Auslastung ist natürlich krass, ne.
Also quasi zwei CPU Kerne, ein 1,5 CPU Kerne voll für ein Video.
Aber so ist es halt, wenn man kein Hardware-Decoding hat.
So, dann probieren wir das nochmal mit dem Addon aus,
den jetzt jemand vorgeschlagen hat.
Aber sollte keinen großen Unterschied machen, weil alles CPU-Decoded ist.
Ähm, der Bildschirmarbeit-Tor ist am Start zwei Monate.
Huge.
Nächsten Monat brauche ich satt neue Sub-Batches.
Wie hieß das Ding nochmal?
H264EFI, ne, ja.
Für Firefox.
Huge Addon, 23.000 User.
Ich glaube, man musste gar nichts machen, einfach installieren.
I got it.
Vlog 60 FPS Videos, warum?
Ach, guck mal.
Da zeigt er gar kein 4K an.
Kann das sein?
Dass er das nicht mag im Firefox?
Oder kann das sein, dass das 1044p prinzipiell nur verfügbar ist in VP9?
Natürlich ist es in Full HD, braucht das Ganze natürlich deutlich weniger CPU-Last, ne?
Naja, deutlich braucht weniger CPU-Last.
Wir können jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das Video tatsächlich nur verfügbar ist in VP9.
Remove extension, remove.
Wir installieren jetzt einfach mal eine Runde YouTube-Download.
Search.
Bestes Tool, YouTube.dl.
Weiß gar nicht, ob das dabei ist.
YouTube.dl.
Das ist so ein Programm, wo ich mir überlegen würde,
wie man das installieren kann, weil sich da oft was ändert.
Ich lade jetzt mal mein eigenes Video runter, oder ich lasse mir mal anzeigen,
was es für Optionen für mein eigenes Video gibt.
Warum mache ich das eigentlich?
YouTube.dl.
Minus F.
Minus Groß F.
Einfügen.
YouTube.dl ist zu, oder war das Minus Kleine F?
Ich glaube, das YouTube.dl ist zu alt.
Das YouTube.dl ist zu alt, was im Repo drin ist.
Dann müssen wir uns YouTube.dl so installieren.
Groß F für die Option habe ich doch.
Geht nicht.
Zu alt.
YouTube.dl.
Wie installiert man das eigentlich?
Ich habe das immer nur aus den Arch-User-Repos installiert.
Installation.
Ja, jawoll.
Hauptsache mal irgendwie Curlpipen irgendwo hin.
Was downloade ich da eigentlich?
Egal, einfach Curl ausführen, runterladen, gut ist.
Allerdings hier bei mir lokal hin und nicht das Thema.
Was ist das?
Ist das Go?
Oder was ist das?
In was ist das programmiert?
Ah.
Pysson.
Binary Pysson.
Was?
Ach, weil ich Sudo davor gemacht habe, Alter.
Warum mache ich da auch Sudo davor?
Bisschen geknackt.
CHown und jetzt auf Peppy.
Nee.
Test.
Test heißt er ja, der User.
Okay, CHmod.
Okay, jetzt können wir das Ganze noch mal machen, alles in meinem lokalen YouTube.dl.
Und jetzt sehen wir mal, was hat denn das YouTube für Video?
Okay, VP9, VP9, also 1440 ist nur in VP9 verfügbar.
Was sagt rum?
Das ist doch ein Problem, was mein Video hat, oder?
Weil ich hab mir letztens erst von der Hexe ein Video runtergeladen.
Und da war das vielleicht bei ihm auch nur 1080p.
Ein Battlefield Gameplay von ihm runtergeladen und ich bilde mir ein, das konnte ich in der
besten Quali, Alter, geh weg Werbung.
Das konnte ich in der besten Quali runterladen in 1044p als H264.
Oder war das nur 1080p?
Okay, war nur 1080p, ich hab nix gesagt.
Ansonsten wäre eigentlich auch kein Problem, weil das Schöne ist ja, man hat hier so viel
Software dabei.
Es ist überhaupt kein Problem zu sagen, YouTube Download.
Sagen wir jetzt hier F, ich zeige euch mal, wie das geht.
Wir wollen die beste Videoqualität plus irgendwie halbwegs gute Audioqualität runterladen.
So, und dann ist es super easy.
Man kann nämlich einfach das Video konvertieren, wenn man FFmpeg hat.
Okay, das werde ich jetzt nicht runter, das ist sinnlos.
Zumindest kann man einfach FFmpeg installieren und gut ist.
Und FFmpeg ist eine Sache, die braucht man eh immer.
Vielleicht schon drauf.
FFmpeg braucht man eh immer.
Abort.
FFmpeg beste, ohne FFmpeg gehe ich nicht mehr aus dem Haus.
Also ich muss sagen, bisher sehr unproblematische Distribution hier, gefällt mir gut.
Vor allem besser als RPM gefuddelt.
Rund 50 Viewer, ja übelst huge.
Seit ich hier Sellout gemacht habe auf YouTube, einmal den Stream verlinkt und einmal einen
Community Post auf YouTube gemacht, gibt es übelst die übelsten Viewer.
Das ist mega nice.
POG, POG, POGgers, POGchamp, habe ich überhaupt noch irgendwas anderes hier drinnen?
Nein.
Huge.
Ich würde sagen, da müssen wir mal die Camera getten hier.
Da Fobi, Twitch Prime, nice, dankeschön.
Easy.
So, ähm, also Lelungswind gefällt mir bisher ganz gut.
Was könnte man noch ausprobieren?
Ich meine, die Pakete müssen wir nicht gucken, das ist ein ganz normales Ubuntu.
Ubuntu 1804, da gibt es nichts zusätzliches, was man groß gucken muss.
Oh, es geht da unten ab.
Dateimanager wird das Standard Nautilus sein, ohne irgendwas.
Mir gefällt ehrlich gesagt, mir gefällt die Optik von Mint nicht.
Wow, was jetzt?
Monka schlieren, bilden.
Ähm, also die default-Gui gefällt mir nicht.
Also das default-Theme gefällt mir nicht.
Wir gucken mal, äh, wie ändert man das jetzt?
Ah, das Monke, gucken wir mal, wie was ändert.
Sag mal, irgendwie spackt das übelst rum gerade.
Wie ändert man das hier?
Themes.
Settings.
Battery-Move, yes, keine Ahnung, was das tut.
Ah, auch das ist ja schön.
Man hat sogar einen Theme-Manager mit dabei.
Das ist, das ist huge.
Und, ach guck mal, die haben ja noch viel mehr.
Nice.
Dark Blue.
Und jetzt?
Ach nee, man muss die Eigens komplett ändern, ne.
Dark Blue.
Gibt es, ähm, kann man nicht, kann man nicht einfach alles, alles auf einmal ändern lassen?
Kann man nicht alles auf einmal ändern lassen?
Anscheinend nicht, ja.
So doof, dass man nicht einfach ein Button hat, äh, Blue-Theme und gut ist.
So muss man das jetzt hier quasi.
Ich meine, es ist cool, dass es geht, ja.
Oh, das ist doch schick, das ist doch schick.
Manjaro, nee, Mint.
So ausprobieren gerade hier.
Minty Borders, Minty Dark.
Oh, das ist doch, so ist das doch was, so ist das doch nice.
Außer, dass die Fenster schlieren bilden, aber das ist okay.
Irgendwie, der rumspackt, wenn ich, wahrscheinlich weil Vmw die Maus crappt oder so.
Probieren wir mal, wartet mal, probieren wir mal, ob das...
Ja, Vmw, komm, äh, New, Exclusive Mode, jetzt passiert nichts mehr.
Oh, es macht einen Sound, hört ihr das?
Gepegasound.
Moment, ich hab Exclusive Mode angemacht.
Okay, das ist so eine Geschichte, wie es Windows auch hat, die benutze ich aber eh nicht.
Schick, okay, also das Dark Team gefällt mir schon mal gut.
Was haben wir dann standardmäßig so dabei?
Liegt safe an Vmw, ja, denke ich auch.
Na, was machst du für Sachen Abel durcheinander?
Wir haben gerade das neue Manjaro installiert, äh, nicht Manjaro, das neue Mint installiert.
Gucken wir mal, wie das ist.
Ich muss sagen, bisher macht es einen echt roten Eindruck.
Was haben wir denn hier unten?
Ah, Update, der Update Manager.
Update, okay, bam.
Brrr, das ist aber hier der Spinner of Speed hier.
Please set up system snapshots.
Die haben einen GUI dabei für Snapshots.
Oh, das ist cool, das gefällt mir.
Wie macht man das?
Select Snapshot, erst sind BTFS.
Na gut, BTF, das kann ich nicht selecten, weil ich hab kein BTFS Filesystem.
Oder hab ich ein BTFS Filesystem?
Äh.
Warte mal, ich nehm das jetzt am besten raus.
X4 ist es.
DF minus T, siehst du mal.
Ah, nice, es gibt, es gibt, das finde ich das Coole.
Es gibt für alles immer unter Linux, meistens zumindest, eine simple Variante.
Man muss so bloß wissen, ja.
Oder man muss nachgucken.
X4, was passiert denn jetzt, wenn ich dem sage, ich will ein BTFS Snapshot.
Das ist ja auch so was, wo sich die Leute nicht drauf einigen können, wenn man den Kram ausspricht, ne.
BTFS, Butter, Better.
Next.
Ah, device does not have a BTFS application.
Okay, da ist, aber wenigstens erkennt das, das Ding, R-Sync.
Okay, R-Sync.
Find mount.
Ach, stimmt, find mount, ja.
Ja, ja.
Das ist auch, wo du checken kannst, ob, ob, ob, ob ein Ordner ein mount point ist oder nicht, ne.
B3FS, das juckt keiner, was da technisch dahinter steht.
B3FS.
Select snapshot location.
SDR1.
Next.
Äh, wie groß, wie groß wird das Snapshot jetzt sein?
Hat er das jetzt irgendwie berechnet?
Okay, ich find's auf jeden Fall cool, dass sie eine standard, eine Snapshot-Geschichte dabei haben.
Ich find's wichtig, dass solche Geschichten standardmäßig dabei sind.
Es ist weiß, es ist super easy, Sachen nach zu installieren.
Aber das, das ist wirklich eine runde Geschichte, was man jetzt...
Local Mirror, yes, wollen wir haben.
Wir wollen irgendwas in Deutschland haben.
Wieso habe ich bei df-h so viele Loops?
Je nachdem, da hast du USB-Stick dran oder Temp gemountet irgendwie oder was auch immer.
Das ist aber normal. Irgendwelche Device-Dinger, die sich da reinhängen.
Ach guck mal, man kann... also ich muss sagen, ich find das echt gut.
Das ist total gut gemacht, also das ist wirklich gut gemacht für Linux-Verhältnisse.
Unter Manjaro fodelst du dich da erstmal ab, bis du nen deutschen Mirror drin hast.
Gut, ich meine, außer man weiß aus dem Kopf, die...
Find ich cool, gefällt mir wirklich gut bis jetzt.
Find ich schick.
Was ich bis heute absolut furchtbar finde, das ist...
You mount und nicht unmount.
Ja, das mach ich... bei sowas ver-tippe ich mich auch ganz gerne mal.
Weil ich mich mittlerweile bei mount hab ich mich dran gewöhnt.
Midnight Commander, glaub ich nicht.
Muss ich ehrlich auch sagen, verwende ich nie.
Ich verwende nie, äh, quasi Fallmanager.
Ich mach das alles auf Konsole.
Entweder wird zepet, es wird gemovet, sonst was.
Nee, ist echt drauf.
So, wie macht man jetzt Updates?
Ranger, ich verstehe den Sinn nicht, warum man Ranger verwendet.
Ganz ehrlich, ich leuchte mir nicht ein.
Also jeder soll, ich meine, es soll im Endeffekt jeder machen, was er will, ja.
Ich verstehe den Vorteil von Ranger nicht.
Wenn ich, wenn ich, wenn ich Dateien verschieben will, mach ich einfach ein MV.
Target, gut ist.
Oder wenn ich mir ein Bild anzeigen lassen will, mach ich...
Also, wozu?
Die schöne CLI Ästhetik.
Ich finde, das ist, ich finde, ein CLI Fallmanager ist was, was...
eigentlich kein Mensch danach gefragt hat so richtig.
Aber ich weiß, es ist beliebt.
Ich weiß aber nicht so genau, warum, ehrlich gesagt.
Oh, damit wird getriggert.
Triggern ist Jugendwort des Jahres.
Habt ihr das gelesen, ja?
Nee, doch nicht.
Was, nicht triggern?
Triggern, ja.
Ach, das hat nicht gewonnen, oder was?
Was hat gewonnen?
Okay, also, was war?
Alles gut, das sagt kein Mensch mehr.
Das ist voll out.
Alman oder Kartoffel, sagt eigentlich...
Ja, doch, das hörst du manchmal, aber finde ich auch knackt.
Prachteln, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Pratan, Pratina, Russisch Schleif...
Hab ich noch nie gehört.
Bot, klar.
Brexit-Ting, sagt man das wirklich?
Bruder muss los.
Das ist schon wieder so out.
Das verwendet auch kein Mensch mehr.
Bruder muss los, das ist so alt.
Besten ist immer noch Bruder muss Koss.
Nein, Bruder muss Koss, will ich suchen.
Warum für Kuck?
Jetzt müssen wir heute auf Google, weil es das nicht findet.
Bruder muss Koss.
Beste hier.
Das ist so dumm, dass es schon wieder lustig ist.
Bruder muss Koss.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Butter Golem.
Das sagt auch keiner, oder?
Fat Shaming.
Anzeige ist raus.
Gleichberechtigten Beauftragte ist informiert.
Butter Golem.
Chaya.
Chabo.
Pornern.
Cringe, ja das verwendet man.
Ehre genommen verwendet man auch.
Der Rest ist so, wir brauchen einfach möglichst viele Wörter,
die sich irgendwie jugendlich anhalten.
Das verwendet auch kein Mensch.
Bruder muss los ist so out.
Aber Bruder muss los.
Ich meine, das ist, wenn ich als 35-Jähriger über Jugendworte labere.
Man kann auch sagen, das ist vollkommen falsch.
Aber Bruder muss los, verwendet auch echt keiner.
Cringe zu sagen ist Cringe.
Flex, ja das wird auch verwendet.
Freundschaft plus.
Das ist eigentlich auch nicht so angesagt.
Gönyamin.
Ja, das habe ich tatsächlich schon ein paar Mal gehört.
Habibi.
Ja gut, arabische Wörter sind zurzeit allgemein angesagt.
Hustlen, ja das sagen auch manche Leute.
Kartoffeln haben wir schon.
Keck.
Das sagt man heute noch?
Das war auch schon wieder out.
Klimanotstand.
Lachkick.
Das ist seit Jahren schon verwendet.
Auch kein Mensch mehr.
Lackgesoffen ist auch uralt.
Das Ligma.
Ich will gar nicht wissen, was es ist.
Lowkey.
Bewendet man?
Das verwendet auch keiner.
Macht kein Auge.
Niceness.
Ja, okay vielleicht.
Pillepalle ist uralt.
Verwendet auch kein Mensch.
Plottwist.
Schlurki.
Snatched.
Stabil, ja das ist aber auch schon seit ein paar Jahren so.
Installier den mal, ah ich muss ihn installieren.
Jooligum.
Das hat es echt darauf geschafft.
Wirklich.
Jooligum.
Das ist aus dem, das ist aus hier, wasletztepreis subreddit.
Das ist eben ein kleiner Zettel.
Das ist wasletztepreis Jooligum.
Ja gut, das ist auch angesagt zu sein.
Das ist auch angesagt.
Weilbau, habe ich ja nie gehört.
Jeet, ja aber finde ich knacktes Wort.
Zerstören, ja das ist auch angesagt.
Ich muss ja sagen, wenigstens mal eine Zusammenstellung von Jugendwörtern, die gefühlt so zu 20-25% verwendet
werden.
Bruder Moskos.
Jooligum.
Stimmt, ja das hätten wir auf DuckDuckGo suchen können.
Ja mach mal, mach mal Upgrade hier.
Klimanotions habe ich auch noch nie gehört.
Keine Ahnung.
Wieso hast du eigentlich die komische Angewohnheit alles zu markieren und dann zu kopieren?
Da haben wir irgendwie den Chat-Commando für, ich glaube Ausrufezeichen 1 ausgeschrieben
oder so.
Hast du das eigentlich mitbekommen, dass im ersten Sonic-Trainer Gotta Go Fast mit Bruder
Moskos los übersetzt wurde?
Echt?
Das ist nicht sogar ganz witzig.
Da hat zumindest mal irgendjemand, der ein bisschen jünger ist, an der Übersetzung gearbeitet.
Ganz ehrlich, eigentlich ist das eine ziemlich coole Übersetzung.
Bruder Moskos los.
Das ist wirklich cool.
Das ist übelst nice.
Wenn das stimmt, keine Ahnung.
Warum guckst du unter 80 CIS-Mann dir das an?
Warum nicht?
Ich bin nicht stark und ich bin kein Held, doch was zu viel ist, ist zu viel.
Für deine Aggressionen war ich immer das Ventil.
Immer in die Fresse.
Genau.
Bruder Moskos los.
Ich finde das gut.
Ganz ehrlich, ich fände die Übersetzung mit Bruder Moskos los, fände ich eigentlich
cool.
Weil ich glaube, die werden ansonsten das Übelscringe übersetzen, nach dem Motto Unschallgeschwindigkeit
oder irgendwie sowas Dummes.
Das sollen sie lieber sagen, Bruder Moskos los.
Wusstest du gar nicht, dass du Faridun oder was?
Die Ärzte hörst du schon ewig.
Ich hör die Ärzte schon.
Seit die Alben noch indiziert wurden, war es heute kein Mensch mehr interessiert.
Ich sage nur Geschwisterliebe oder sowas in der Richtung.
Biege auf dir, du schreist Jaaaaa.
Du hast mal vor x Jahren ein Lied von den Toten Hosen auf YouTube kommentiert.
Ja, habe ich.
Es gibt tatsächlich auch von den Toten Hosen mal ganz gute Sachen.
Der Schäferhunder, der war, den finde ich total beknackt.
War schon nie lustig.
Aber das kann man uns der Linux Mint noch angucken, also bisher muss ich sagen, also
elementary OS war die hübschere, rein optisch, die hübschere Distro vielleicht und auch
eventuell das schöner, vorkonfiguriertere Gesamtpaket, aber insgesamt muss ich sagen,
macht Linux Mint wirklich ziemlich guten Eindruck.
Es ist alles dabei, was man braucht.
Was haben wir denn sonst?
Was haben wir denn zu bieten?
Accessories.
Was hat er für einen Pack, für einen, für einen Kompressions Dings?
X-Archiv, nee, ganz normalen Chrome Archive Manager.
Ich habe da überhaupt nicht drauf geklickt, das hat gerade von alleine geklickt.
Alter, vm, vm wäre nicht rumspacken jetzt.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich gehackt gerade, omg-hexor.
Vielleicht mal gucken, guck mal was der Hexor treibt.
Hier, der Hexor, was macht er?
Er macht... nichts.
Tja, dann scheint es wohl doch an vm zu liegen und nicht, dass ich gehackt sort bin.
Na gut.
Auch okay.
Das System ist up to date.
Mir gefällt das wirklich gut.
So, was haben wir sonst noch dabei?
Ähm, Alter, warum spackt denn die Maus hier gerade so rum?
Was ist das denn?
Archive Manager, Calculator, blablabla, okay, das ist der Geschlecht.
Redshift ist glaube ich diese Geschichte, mit der du es abends dunkler machen kannst,
ne?
Was jetzt aber irgendwie nix, nix macht?
War das nicht Redshift?
Wisst ihr was, Leute, wir starten mal neu, äh, Reboot, weil wir am Updates installiert,
schadet nie was.
Ja, jetzt ist das, dass der Bildschirm gelber wird, das ist praktisch, dass, dass nutze
ich gern sowas.
Ups.
Kann sein, dass es einen richtigen Grafik-Driver braucht, ja, das ist möglich, dass es nicht
funktioniert.
Ja, wahrscheinlich wird es mit dem VMA Grafik-Driver nicht funktionieren.
Ist das hier Redshift, da unten?
Gucken wir mal.
Ja.
Das war's für heute.
Hallo!
Wie findest du den jetzt mit? Ich find's wirklich gut, gefällt mir echt. Hätte ich gar nicht mit gerechnet.
Oh, Steam updaten sich mit ultra hässlicher Schrift, aber das haben viele...
Das hat viele ursprüngliche Windows-Software, hat hässliche Schrifte unter Linux.
Aber mir gefällt das wirklich ziemlich gut. Sehr nice.
Huge Pog.
Das sind, sag mal, ich... Es geht nichts über E3, ja, finde ich auch.
E3-Beste, ich mal ganz ehrlich. Das ist schön für Leute, die Windows-Style-Desktop mögen.
Aber ich bin halt jemand.
Ich bin halt jemand, der will das besonders.
Aber ich bin halt jemand. Ich bin halt jemand, der will das besonders minimalistisch und tastaturzentriert.
Deswegen sieht mein Standard-Desktop, den ich unter Linux verwende, auch so aus.
Hast du einen bevorzugen Remote-Desktop-Klan für iOS? Nee.
Oh.
Das ist mein... Ups, hab's verstellt.
Das ist mein Desktop, den ich auch auf der Arbeit verwende.
Alles Tastatur, steuerbar. Neue Anwendungen starten per Tastatur.
Ja, keine Ahnung, Anwendungen per Tastatur starten mit Auto-Vervollständigungssuche.
Mit Auto-Vervollständigungssuche. Mit den Qualen. Das ist ein wechselnder Hintergrund.
Das ist ein wechselnder Hintergrund.
Ich hab ja ein paar Hintergründe drin.
Der Image-Front ist ein bisschen verkackt hier oben, seh ich gerade.
Was ist eigentlich genau deine Arbeit? Ausrufezeichen, Beruf.
Da hab ich nämlich ein extra Kommando schon für, weil das jedes Mal kommt, die Frage. Mehrfach.
Profi ist auch toll, ja.
Ich bin halt jemand, der mag das minimalistisch, ja.
Also, ich verstehe jeden, der sagt, er hätte gerne ein bisschen mehr Windows-Style, so Windows-klassischen Windows-Desktop-Style.
Ja, so mit Icons auf dem Desktop und so.
Fenster, die man rumschieben kann und Fenster, die man minimieren, verkleinern und geduldens machen kann.
Aber ich bin halt jemand, der steht auf Tastaturbedienung.
Ja, Desktop-Switchen per Tastatur.
Ähm, ich mein, im Prinzip, ich brauche zu 90% zwei Anwendungen.
Das ist mein Terminal und mein Webbrowser, sonst brauch ich nix.
Wie ist das eigentlich unter E3-WM mit Multi-Monitor-Setup? Ist kein Problem.
Das hat mit E3 gar nix zu tun, das musst du halt von Hand machen, musst du mit X, Xrandere.
Musst du halt dein Monitor-Setup einstellen.
Manchmal ist es ein bisschen nervig, wenn die ganze Minimalismus, wenn man zum Beispiel mal seinen Notebook an Beamer anschließen muss.
Ja, da muss man halt vorher gucken, dass man sich das passende X-Render-Command hat.
Aber für mich geht nix über, guck mal.
Ich hab mein eigenes Video-View boosted hier.
Ich hab's unter Lidl fünfmal refreshed. Weiß gar nicht, warum ich mein Video aufhab.
Das sind Comments, die gehen runter wie sonst was.
Ich liebe einfach diese Professionalität von Max, man hört einfach raus, dass es sich in keinem Fall um Halbwissen handelt, so wie es bei anderen der Fall ist.
Das ist doch was.
Ja, Chousen, je nachdem in welchem Bereich du unterwegs bist, kannst du es natürlich unter Linux vergessen.
Aber Video-Bearbeitung zum Beispiel ist unter Linux ziemlicher Sack.
Foto-Bearbeitung auch.
Dafür hat es halt in anderen Bereichen seine Stärken.
Aber Video-Bearbeitung zum Beispiel ist unter Linux ziemlicher Sack.
Foto-Bearbeitung auch.
Dafür hat es halt in anderen Bereichen seine Stärke.
Als Entwicklungsplattform für Software ist es meiner Meinung nach Windows haushoch überlegen.
Außer halt für Windows-Software.
Ja, ne.
Siehst du großen Sinn darin Wayland auf Wayland zu wechseln, zum Beispiel auf Sway?
Ne, weil es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Ich hab's schonmal probiert vor einem Jahr oder so.
Sway mit Wayland.
Ich hatte sogar Probleme Fenster zu resize.
Da hab ich mir gedacht, den Scheiß geb ich mir nicht.
Da warte ich noch mal 15 Jahre und dann ist es okay wahrscheinlich.
Sinov420, POG.
Subscriber.
Eigentlich schön.
Windows sagt mit dem ganzen Update, naja.
Ich finde, die Windows-Update-Politik, die sie jetzt fahren, ist leider notwendiges Übel, was du hast unter Windows.
Viele Leute haben Service-Packs nicht installiert und hatten da auch keinen Bock drauf.
Windows hatte nicht grundlos so einen unsicheren Ruf.
Die Updates müssen unter Windows sein.
Die Update-Politik, die sie fahren, mit 20 Updates ist beknackt, ja.
Was war das für ein nettes LS?
Das ist kein normales LS.
Das ist Exa.
Wenn sich das...
Exa.
Ah, Exa.
Das ist ein...
Fake LS.
Vorher hatte ich immer LS++.
Das war ein Perl-Programm, das war mir aber zu langsam.
Exa, beste.
Da sieht sogar ein LS in einem Directory fancy aus.
Und das wichtigste Programm ist immer noch das da.
Bist du ein Keller-gebräunter Computer-Nerd?
Aber sowas von...
Ich bin huge-braun, bin ich.
Ich bin richtig zu lull schon.
Ja, zuverlässig Windows-Update-reburten wäre nicht schlecht.
Ja, Chosen, genau das ist das Problem, was ich auch hab.
Ich verwende...
Software unter Linux und Software unter Windows.
Und für beides gibt es umgedreht teilweise keine Alternativen so richtig.
Deswegen war die sinnvollste Variante für mich...
Windows als Hauptsystem und Linux immer VM.
Wenn man natürlich das Problem hat, dass man sowohl Linux-Programme als auch Windows-Programme hat,
die irgendwelche Hardware-Geschichten brauchen,
Zugriff auf Grafikkarte für irgendwelche Render-Geschichten,
dann tut es halt eine VM nicht.
XR, ja, genau.
Du beherrschst Linux genauso wie Englisch.
Kann man Englisch mit der Tastatur bedienen?
Lollcat in die Bash-AC, Lollcat ist eh das Allerwichtigste.
GPU-Paththrough ist mittlerweile ziemlich gut,
GPU-Paththrough bringt dir allerdings nichts,
wenn du VM-Ware unter Windows verwendest.
Ja, Dualboot geht mir auch auf den Sack.
Deswegen, für mich ist es so die beste Variante.
Windows mit einem Linux in der VM.
Funktioniert für mich einfach am besten.
Übrigens, das ist das Programm hier,
was ich auf Fiverr beauftragt habe.
Also im Prinzip besteht das Fiverr-Programm
aus 50 Zeilen C-Sharpcode und aus 118 Zeilen HTML.
Ja, was klippt.
Und davon ist das meiste sogar noch Styling.
Hast du auf der Arbeit auch Linux-Nativ?
Ja, zum Glück, zum Glück.
Warum Dualboot scheiße?
Weil du immer alles beenden musst und neu starten musst.
Also in Rechnung.
Programme kannst du ja wieder laden lassen,
wobei das auch teilweise nicht richtig funktioniert.
Es ist halt einfach, super easy, Desktop zu switchen
und du bist von Windows in Linux drin.
Da kommst du mit, also den Komfort
kommst du halt mit keinem Dualboot ran.
Sind bei dir über Mint YouTube-Videos
mit Mikro-Rollklaren versehen?
Nee, allerdings, ich habe Mint hier auch in der VM verwendet.
Das heißt, bei mir ist das komplette Decoding
über die CPU gelaufen in der VM.
Da hat nichts geruckelt.
Es kann aber durchaus sein, dass es, wenn du GPU-Decoding machst,
halt wenn du es richtig auf deiner Kiste installiert hast,
dass Mint dann ruckelt, weil da Dreiberum spackt.
Und läuft das Fiverr-Programm?
Nö, ich hab noch keine, ich hab noch keine, ähm,
kein Code bekommen von den Programmierern auf Fiverr.
Also das ist ja, das ist ja das, was ich gebaut hab
für, für hier Chat mit Steinen.
Und das Gleiche hab ich auf Fiverr beauftragt,
dass sie das, dass sie auch sowas bauen.
Weil ich gucken wollte, was rauskommt.
Schon WSL ausprobiert, ja, ja.
Geht in die richtige Richtung, ist aber keine Alternative
zu einer richtigen Windows, äh, zu einer ordentlichen Linux-VM
oder zu einer ordentlichen Linux-Installation.
Fängt dir allein schon daran an,
dass du keine grafischen Programme richtig verwenden kannst
unter WSL.
Du kannst zwar den Xserver installieren für Windows,
aber versuch damit mal irgendwas, irgendwas zu machen,
was außer ein paar statische, statische Sachen rausgeht.
Was natürlich richtig Next Level wäre,
Wine unter WSL.
Das wär was, oder?
Huge.
Welche Codesprachen beherrschst du?
Oh, da haben wir mal eine,
da haben wir mal eine,
eine Textdatei für gemacht.
Wie hab ich denn die genannt?
Progress?
Ja.
Da haben wir mal eine Textdatei für gemacht,
weil das auch öfter als Frage kommt.
Also, meine Lieblingssprachen, meine Lieblings,
meine zwei Lieblingssprachen sind eindeutig.
C-Sharp unter.NET und Ruby.
Die kann ich auch alle beide ziemlich gut.
Python geht auch halbwegs so.
Shell und Bash kann ich aufgrund dessen,
dass ich früher mal bei einem Hoster gearbeitet hab,
auch relativ gut.
C&C++, es geht so.
Ich krieg damit Sachen gebacken,
allerdings hab ich da keinen Bock drauf.
Assembler krieg ich rudimentär auch was zusammengewurstet.
Für Java?
Nein, Java hab ich da gar nicht aufgeführt.
Java würd ich auch hinkriegen,
aber Java will ich nicht hinkriegen.
JavaScript, TypeScript, CSS, HTML ist auch ganz okay.
Ich würd nicht sagen,
dass ich da wirklich extrem gut drinne bin,
aber passt ganz gut.
Ruby krieg ich auch ganz gut hin.
Das ist ja im Prinzip auch JVM-Basis.
PowerShell hab ich mal ein bisschen was mitgemacht.
PHP hab ich auch ein bisschen was gemacht.
Und Rust hab ich mir auch schon mal angeguckt.
Und da haben wir uns,
da hab ich mir eine Weile Gedanken zugemacht
und ich glaube,
das sind alle Sprachen, die ich kann.
Bevor zuckst du Vue gegenüber Angular und React?
Ja, hauptsächlich weil Vue super easy ist zum Einsteigen.
Wie viel Geld hast du ausgehend?
Once auf Fiverr?
So 100 Euro oder so insgesamt.
7 von 11 haben abgesagt.
Wollten das nicht programmieren.
Und die anderen mal gucken, was rauskommt.
Der Fiverr Brokers guckt meinen Stream.
Ja, das wäre fände ich interessant,
wenn der da gucken würde.
Glaube ich aber eher nicht.
Das waren alles, würde ich mal sagen,
das waren Inder und Pakistaner zum größten Teil,
die ihre Programmierkünste
so günstig angeboten haben auf Fiverr.
Ich glaube, da ist keiner drin, der Deutsch versteht
und ich glaube,
das ist ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen ein bisschen
... ich glaube, da ist keiner drin, der Deutsch versteht
und das Team guckt.
VSL 2, ja VSL 2, bin ich auch mal gespannt drauf.
Hast du Empfehlung für einen VPN Kill Switch
unter Linux?
Gibt es was fertig?
Was Genau Willst Du Machen
Dass Du das Jetzt Muss man Mal Erklären also Irgendwas was Automatisch was beenden soll oder so
Glaubst Du dass Linux Jemals Mainstream wird Linux ist Mainstream
Linux ist fast Überall Mainstream außer auf dem desktop
Guck Mal okay Sagen wir mal so
nicht nur Linux
Die Playstation hat Als Betriebssystemen in BSD Darauf
Aber Ansonsten 90 prozent der Geräte wo man so tagtäglich
direkt und indirekt verwendet werden Wahrscheinlich
Linux oder BSD Sein
Das iPhone ist BSD Ganz Ganz Tief die Playstation ist BSD Ganz Ganz Tief
und die Meisten Anderen Sachen sind Linux
Was Empfiehlst Du Als Grundlagen Für Jemand der auf Linux wechseln will Ja das ist gute frage
Das Einzige was ich Empfehlen würde ist
Dass man nicht denkt dass es ein Windows ist mit anderer Oberfläche
Weil auch wenn Sowas wie Mint Hier Beispielsweise
Easy Eats As Fuck Ja Geh Aus
Auch wenn Sowas wie Mint auf den ersten blick
Ein, bisschen aussieht wie ein Windows und Wahrscheinlich Wahrscheinlich Gerade Absichtlich auch deswegen so aussieht
ist es unter der haube halt ein Komplett anderes Betriebssystem
Was auch Komplett anders
Funktioniert in manchen Bereichen
Das Einzige was man sich Eigentlich Merken Muss ist dass man nicht mit seinem Windows wüssten an Linux dran geht
und im Vergleich zu Windows wo viele Leute
Panische Angst Vor einer Kommandozeile Haben was ich bis heute nicht so Ganz Verstehen Kann
Obbei doch Wenn Ich mir Windows und Batch angucke Kann Ich das Verstehen unter Linux darf man halt keine angst vor der Kommandozeile haben
Also Sobald Es Ein, bisschen spezifischer wird wird man über kurz oder lang nicht dran Vorbeikommen
Da Muss Ich der Kasse Schelz Kripto werden oder so aber ein, bisschen Kommandozeile muss sein unter Linux
Haben sie angegeben warum es nicht programmiert wurde auf Fiverr? Nö wirklich wir haben uns ja vorhin angeguckt
Der Eine hat es nicht verstanden der andere wollte 700 euro Für. Haben anstatt 22 was er haben wollte ursprünglich
Ja 700 euro vor 200 zeilen
Ich Wusste heute nach geht garantiert nicht Nach Einigen Geflänkel Gingen wir zu ihr
Kam Jetzt noch was zu dem vpn kill switch Muss Du Musst Mir Mal Genau Erklär was Du Machen
Könntest Du was wie Auto SSH verwenden zum Aufbauen Aber nicht wirklich Für. Vpn
Für. Den Durchschnittsanwender auf dem desktop jahrzehnten hast Du recht das Glaube Ich nicht Ich Glaube Linux auf dem desktop wird nie Mainstream Werden
Bin Ich Jetzt Aber auch nicht so wild
Das Glaube Ich Aber dass wir das ich Glaube nicht dass wir das Hier Mal Sehen Werden
Okay Er Schreibt Für. Einen Laptop Ich MöcHte dass Mein vpn abkackt das internet ganz aus ist
Ich Kein Erinnert habe nur um Wieder zum vpn Connecten Zu Können Moment was Du Willst das wenn das vpn abkackt dass das internet ausgeschaltet wird
Also Du Willst Quasi alles Durch Den vpn tunnel Leiten oder wie also Du Willst nicht aus Versehen
Sachen über das normale internet Schicken
Wenn das vpn abkackt hast Du ein Modem oder Kann das dann Mikrotik Router Ich habe das Unity Media Modem aber Mikrotik Router routet halt Einfach nur davor Dahinter hinter dem Modem
Vpn das ist eine gute Frage
Also Ich meine den Kompletten den Kompletten traffic das klingt so ein bisschen als willst du Dinge machen
Aber das ist einfach nur ein Modem
Das ist einfach nur ein Modem
Vpn das ist eine gute Frage also ich meine den Kompletten den Kompletten traffic das klingt so ein bisschen als willst du Dinge machen die man nicht feststellen kann aber das ist ja dein Ding
Also wenn du dann die fault Route über das vpn machst also was du kannst ja bei Open vpn kannst du ja einstellen dass du alles durch den tunnel alles durch den tunnel schleifen willst
Du hast auf jeden fall schon mal nicht das problem dass Sachen vielleicht so ins internet gehen wenn das vpn abkackt sicherzustellen dass das da muss da bin ich ehrlich gesagt überfragt so aus dem stehgreif
Da müsste ich mir das müsste ich mir erstmal Gedanken zu machen
Das kann man 100 pro einstellen das ist so eine typische linux geschichte wo ich dir sagen kann das geht garantiert und wahrscheinlich weil man weiß wie sogar auch relativ easy
Leider kann man schreibt der twitch zuschauer
Leider kann man mit linux basierten betriebssystem nicht viele top titel zocken jedenfalls war es so wo ich das letzte mal probiert habe ich glaube das liegt daran dass wir uns immer alle recht haben
Na das liegt an was anderem aber du hast recht ja aber das liegt an was anderem und ich glaube das ist eine der punkte auch wenn ich glaube dass google stadia übelster griff ins klo wird
Wo ich glaube dass uns google stadia tatsächlich was bringen könnte für spiele die unter linux laufen oder für spiele die sagen wir mal nicht unbedingt für spiele die unter linux laufen
Spiele die nicht mehr auf windows only technologie basieren ich glaube da könnte uns stadia wirklich was bringen
Die sache warum spiele heutzutage nicht unter linux anderen betriebssystem laufen ist hauptsächlich die weil die sachen verwenden die nur unter windows da sind und kein bock haben die meisten engines wie unity und so würden es ja hergeben
Und kein bock haben ein paar anpassungen vorzunehmen für andere betriebssysteme
Dadurch dass allerdings google stadia die server auch auf linux basis sind oder was bsd ich glaube ich glaube linux basis kann ich mir gut vorstellen dass die anzahl der spiele die unter linux läuft steigen wir sobald sollte stadia irgendwie erfolgreich sein
Ja und anti cheat ist tatsächlich ein problem wenn du manche spiele unter linux spielst kannst du ja sagen dass als cheaters erkannt wirst oder aber die anti cheat software nicht funktioniert und dich das gar nicht spielen lässt
Ja Captain Sieger ich weiß was du meinst aber da fällt mir jetzt grad nichts ein
Man bräuchte irgendeinen hook man bräuchte irgendeinen hook so nach dem motto der mitkriegt wenn wenn interface wenn vpn interface down geht dann
Soll einfach den default geht wenn ich will ersetzen oder sowas und bei den hook an sich ist auch zu blöd du brauchst wirklich was was was was nicht parallel läuft sondern du bräuchte es wirklich den hook da quasi sagt der oder der quasi läuft bevor das interface richtig weg ist
Ich müsste ich mir Gedanken zu machen wie man das schön umsetzen unter linux
Stadia ja wie soll ich sonst aussprechen stadia stadia aber ich finde stadia viel besser
Stadia wird in guter google tradition in drei bis vier jahren eingestampft ja gehe ich auch von aus ich glaube stadia wird ein saumäßig großer griff ins klo werden
Es wäre cool also ich fände es ganz cool wenn ich das durchsetzen würde allein schon aus das vielleicht mehr spiele auf linux laufen
Aber wie gesagt ich habe es im letzten stream gesagt stadia wird mich erst überzeugen wenn ein cs team mit stadia einen major gewinnt dann dann bin ich überzeugt von stadia
Stadia test im stream ich habe bestellt ja ich habe mir letztens eine bestellt eine founders edition wir können das im stream testen ja
130 euro fürs klo wahrscheinlich
Was Tim Sweeney hasst lilos einfach rummen am eint
Es ist aber auch schwierig anti cheat auf einer nicht auf so einer nicht native plattform weil vieles von dem sieht wahrscheinlich
Wirklich aus wie cheats wenn es unter windows laufen würde das das das zeug huckt sich ja sonst wo rein also ich kann es verstehen wenn man
Wenn man sagt dass multiplayer competitive spiele nichts unter dem anderen betriebssystem als dem offiziellen support gespielt werden das kann ich verstehen
Ja rein aus cheater problematik ich meine linux mit den ganzen mit den ganzen winelibrary geschichten ich meine wer soll ich dann zum
Beispiel dafür schützen eine gepatchte version zu installieren die irgendwelche cheat geschichten ermöglicht oder so
Das gibt das gibt eine ganz große einfalls tor max ich habe auch wiedergesehen hast du auch ein any juby 3 mega bist du zufrieden
Ja ich bin sehr zufrieden mit eurem planet drucker huge also für den preis ist er wirklich nice
Keiner gekauft ich habe ja ich habe ja auch diesen diesen ufo mod gemacht das mit der mit dem lab mit der lampe ja der hier also das
Ist wirklich super der kostet der war sogar billiger irgendwie dann gibt es teilweise 100 160 170 euro oder 3d drucker ist wirklich cool also kann man
Empfehlen für den preis hast du schon mal solos linux getestet habe ich noch aber den finde ich echt zu empfehlen 328 what
Warum ist das so teuer ich habe das für moment ich muss mal kurz gucken vielleicht habe ich ja auch kein miss erzählt
Wie viel habe ich denn dafür bezahlt ich habe dafür bezahlt wo steht es denn angaben zur bestellung
Wo steht es denn stelldetails ich bin zu durft es zu finden 280 habe ich bezahlt warum ist das ding jetzt so übertrieben
Teuer glaubst du auf linux ist es erheblich schwer ordentliches anti cheat zu machen ja glaube ich glaube ich unter windows tauscht
Ihr keine irgendwelche system libraries aus mit irgendwelchen gepatchten kram oder so zumindest nicht denn oder 15
Also ich denke linux bietet mehr möglichkeiten unter der haube zu cheaten aber ich glaube eh dass die zukunft des
anti cheatings nicht mehr in besserer in besserer anti cheat software liegt sondern ich denke dass die zukunft des
anti cheatings in k.i. basiertem auswertung von spiele stats liegt weil du kannst cheater die quasi
durch die cheats besser sind als sie sein sollen wahrscheinlich denke ich mal ganz gut mit mit statistik auswertung
die identifizieren pangolin 13 twitch prime dankeschön
Gucken, dass ich nix vergessen hab an Zaps
Nee, hab ich nicht
Telekom launcht auch so'n Stadion
Ach stimmt, das wollten wir uns ja mal angucken
Magenta Gaming, oder wie hieß das?
Magenta Game... Nee, wie hieß der Kram?
Ach doch, Magenta Gaming, ja
Das wird auch so'n Rohrkrepierer, Leute
Wie gesagt, ich denke Stadia wird schon ein Rohrkrepierer
Aber Magenta Gaming wird nochmal dann
Du musst hier dann auch spielen
Jaja, musst du, musst du
Kannst dich deine Steam Library einfach importieren
So einfach ist das nicht
Der Josen schreibt
Du kannst eine VM zu betreiben, die eine Grafikkarte durchgereicht hat
Kannst du machen
Kann ja auch wahrscheinlich die Onboard-Grafikkarte oder so sein
Und das dann abzugreifen und trotzdem in nem Fenster die Anzeigen zu lassen
Ohne nen extra Monitor mit Glass
Das hab ich aber noch nie gemacht
Looking Glass ist quasi
Ein Ding, was aus deinen KVM, VMs das Bild von der Grafikkarte abgreifen kann und in nem extra Fenster rendern
So abgedrehtes Geschiss gibt's ja nur unter Linux
Also wenn du quasi ne KVM, Windows VM unter Linux laufen lassen würdest
Mit Grafikkarten pass-through
Dann wäre das ne Alternative
Halt für Programme, die man unter Windows braucht
Ja für Spiele
Competitive Spiele würd ich aber dann auch nicht drüber spielen
Aber alles andere sollte super benutzbar sein
Schau, der Himmel ist champenklar, schenk uns noch ein Glas Sektar hin
Ein Soloslinux hab ich schon nie probiert
Ja, Ryder, Ryder gehen wir nicht aufn Kekse
CS analysiert schon die Demos der Spiele mit KI, würd mich hier wundern
Das halt ich auch für die Zukunft, was Anti-Cheating anbelangt
Postleitzahl und Ort von Max liegt, warum?
Weil ich wieder auf Amazon gewesen bin
Oh fuck
OMG
League
O-M-G
Magenta Gaming
auch mal unter dem Bild auf
Kommen wir jetzt mal angucken, wie die Schrift so ist
DarkSeam überzeugt mich allerdings schonmal
Ayaya, Neradorn abonniert, zwei Monate lang
Ja, wenn er schon Ayaya schreibt
Dankeschön für den Sub
Ich könnte mal eine Runde Twitch Prime
ist ja laut machen, weil ihr wisst ja
Der Amazon Prime hat, kann das ganze
easy mit Twitch verbinden und einen
Streamer seiner Wahl kostenlos mit
einem TierOne-Sub unterstützen
euch kostet das gar nichts extra und
für den Streamer ist es wie ein ganz
normaler Sub
Magenta Gaming ermöglicht Videospiel auf
nahezu jeder Plattform und Hardware
Okay, Blablabla, Registrierung für die
Beta-Phase startet am 24. August mit mehr als
100 kostenlos verfügbar, was ist denn da drinne?
Worms 1 oder was?
Telekom Festnets bietet ideale
Voraussetzungen für Cloud Gaming
Fuck, wurde vor 14 Tagen abgeschaltet
Aber das muss nämlich Unity Media auch
funktionieren
Mit Magenta Gaming startet...
Ich meld mich da jetzt als Beta-Tester an
Wie meldet man sich da als Beta?
Ach du, man braucht einen Telekom-Anschluss
Ich bin kein Telekom-Kunde
Moment, was ist das für ein Schwachsinn?
Ich klick auf kein Telekom-Kunde und soll mich
da mit Telekom-Login anmelden
Huge Brain
Das ist mal Next Level Telekom-Logik
Gut Leute, da kann ich mich nicht registrieren
So, Registrierung, Telekom, Mobilfunk
Stock-Fotos, Alter
Mein Weg mag das kein Stock-Foto sein, aber
Im Hintergrund ist Huge-Grafik angesagt, wie man
das hier schon mal sieht
Garfield-Card, da hat ja schon die Welt
drauf gewartet
Gibt es irgendjemand, der so schaut, wenn er
Konsolen spielt?
Und das Kind guckt sowieso so
Alter, was für ein Scheiß-Foto
Garfield-Cards spielen die ganzen Pros
Sieht aus wie Playstation-Controller
Okay, keine neue Hardware kaufen
Aus über 100 Games wählen
Nie wieder, ich hab das Gefühl die Telekom
Ich hab das, nee, also wisst ihr, ich glaube
der Telekom-Manager hat die Stadia-Präsentation
gesehen und hat gesagt, Jungs, ich hab die Idee
Wir machen Game-Streaming
Und dann haben die Leute bei der Telekom
alle dann so gesagt, so irgendwie, so
Und der Manager-Typ hat trotzdem gesagt
Hier, Poggers-Leute, Game-Streaming, machen wir
Und dann kommt dann sowas bei raus
Die beste Auswahl, okay, was haben wir denn hier zur Auswahl?
Gravel, hab ich schon nie gehört
Das da kenn ich auch nicht
Evoland hab ich in meiner Merkliste von Steam
Sniper-Warrior, oh, den Krämpel da
Hunting-Simulator
Asterix und Obelix XXL
Also man erkennt schon mal
Einen absoluten Crap-Service dadurch
Dass sie quasi so als Headliner-Titel Asterix und Obelix XXL 2 anbieten
Was haben wir denn sonst noch zur Auswahl?
Kung Fu-Rabbit, man kann den Kram übrigens nicht anklicken
Pro-Cycling-Manager wird hier immer besser
Siberia, ich wusste gar nicht, dass es das überhaupt noch gibt
Cruiser Woods, kenn ich nicht, Criminal Minds, kenn ich auch nicht
Shadow Combs, keine Ahnung
Das sagt mir irgendwas, das ist glaube ich relativ neu
Okay, also, welche Spiele gibt es noch bei Magenta Gaming?
Beliebt, beliebt ohne dass es den Service überhaupt gibt, okay
Simon the Sorcerer, das gibt's noch?
Railway Empire, Project Hyrule's Moon, wird ja immer schlimmer
Project Hospital, das ist dieses Sim-Hospital-Clone
Yiget, die üblichen Abzock-Games
World of Tanks, World of Warships, LOL
King's Bounty, das ist auch irgendwie so ein Pay-to-win-Mobile-Crap, oder?
Offroad Drive, immer dann diese Men of War, das gibt's auch noch?
Men of War, collection pack, was auch immer das ist
Da ist ja 90% alt oder crap
Der Switcher ist am Start, der Switcher 3
Immerhin war ein gescheites Game
Pillars of Eternity ist ja auch gut
Ganz viele Sniper Zeugs, was glaube ich vom deutschen Hersteller ist
Uralte Flugsimulation, uralt, so 15 Jahre alt
Da sind ja die richtigen Racer dabei, die Titel, also die richtigen Blockbuster Titel
sind ja da dabei, bei der Telekom
Huge Gaming Experience, best ever
Was Kingdom Come ist dabei, ja immerhin, weil es ist ein gutes Game
LOL, LOL ist so ein Spiel, ne?
Auch wenn es jetzt nicht zu vergleichen ist, sag mal mal von
Was Aiming und Instant Reactions angeht, wie CS, ja?
Aber es ist trotzdem ein Spiel, wo niemand mehr Latents haben will, als nötig
Zumal LOL auf jeder Büchse läuft
Die beste Auswahl, Leute, ist das
Die beste Auswahl, die beste Auswahl aktueller Titel
Also wenn das die beste Auswahl ist, aktueller Titel
Also, keine Ahnung, wenn das die beste Auswahl ist, dann
Dann mach ich die besten Reaction Videos
NachoLibre sagt, läuft bei der Telekom immer so
Nachdem AWS und Azure groß wurde, kam die Open Telekom Cloud
Was, sowas gibt es?
Okay, das verwendet glaub ich wirklich kein Mensch, das hab ich noch nie gehört
Ja, AWS, vor allem Azure ist ja wahnsinnig angesagt zur Zeit
Open Telekom Cloud hab ich noch nie gehört
Der Magenta Sprachassistent, das ist doch was, das kennt doch
Das kennt doch echt keine Sau
Magenta Smart Speaker, ach du Scheiße, die Telekom
Die sollen mal machen, was sie können, die sollen mal Glasfaserkabel verlegen
Obwohl, das können sie auch nicht
Nachdem, wir gucken uns da jetzt ein Video voran
Das muss ich mir angucken
Und das muss man uns anschauen
magenta sprach oder magenta magenta speak
äh nein
äh sprachassistent
magenta smart home sowas gibt es auch
ach du scheiße
magenta smart von der computer bild auch noch
magenta ok das gibt es auch magenta smart
ok ich muss mir jetzt erstmal den magenta sprachassistent angucken
da müssen jetzt mal kurz da muss bela mal kurz die klappe halten
ähm haben die kein werbevideo dafür
haben die da kein offizielles werbevideo für
jetzt zugreifen da muss doch da muss es doch und da muss doch werbung fürgeben
smart speaker
da muss es doch ein offizielles werbevideo für geben
oder gibt es es gibt es es schon nicht mehr
ah hier ok mir hat ein video geschickt perfekt 40 top
genau es reicht jetzt nicht dass nur microsoft mitlocken was du sagst amazon mitlockt was
du sagst google mitlockt was du sagst jetzt die telekom muss auch mitlocken was du sagst
ok also leute hallo magenta aktiv da hätte ich ja schon mal überhaupt keinen bock drauf
Leute da hätte ich schon mal überhaupt keinen bock drauf durch die wohnung zu schreien hallo
magenta also ich schrei auch nicht durch die wohnung hier irgendwie ok google oder so hallo
magenta aktiviere die situation kino abend
hallo vor allem wer hat sich denn hatten die keine zeit meine gescheite spracherkennung
zu zu zu magenta aktiviere die situation aktiviere die situation hätten sie nicht
die scene nehmen können aktiviere die scene oder irgendwas was sich nach deutsch anhört
der guckt schon so nach dem motto wisst ihr wie der guckt der guckt so nach dem motto
der guckt gerade seinen kameramann an so nach dem motto wollen wir die aufnahme wirklich
nehmen oder wollen wir das noch mal machen wollen wir wollen wir die aufnahme wirklich
nehmen so guckt ja das ist jetzt nicht euer ernst oder das wollen wir doch nicht nehmen
genau it was this moment he knew he was fucked
die situation kino abend aktiviert
oh ist das schlimm
smartspeaker sind generell keine weltneuheit aber ein smartspeaker mit sprachassistent
aus deutschland für deutschland das ist neu
ist das scheiß egal ob das ding aus deutschland kommt oder nicht es muss funktionieren mit
deutsch obwohl er hergestellt wird der kann auch in togo togo enttobago oder wie das heißt
hergestellt werden was mir egal ob es auch der funktioniert gut mit deutschen setzen
was ich ja nicht so anhört ich meine hallo magenta aktiviere die situation kino abend
und was der smartspeaker der telekom so alles drauf hat und was das besondere an ihm ist
das sind die heute bei den netzgeschichten das video nicht richtig synchronisiert oder
liegt es an meiner vm ich glaube das liegt an meiner vm hallo
spiegel mit sprachassistent aus deutschland für deutschland das ist neu und was der smartspeaker
der telekom so alles drauf hat und was das besondere an ihm ist das sind die heute bei
den netzgeschichten
doch eben gerade schon mal sicher und bequem keine leute keine leute aufpassen jetzt die
neuest neuesten bliehenden innovation der telekom aus deutschland keine fernbedienung
oder ab der smartspeaker steuert auf zuruf telekom dienste wie smart home oder enttent
tv
ja dann probieren telekom smart was ja auch übelstacken soll egal ich halte mal die klappe
zum ansatz oder ab der smartspeaker steuert auf telekom dienste wie smart home oder enttent
tv
na dann probieren wir doch mal aus wie das funktioniert hallo magenta mach mal das wohnzimmerlicht
an
erledigt das klappt
ja das ist auch eines der simpelsten sachen ever
erledigt
tja meine serie ist schon mal
tippt der wirkt tippt das ding allen ernstes die buchstaben da gerade ein hab ich das richtig
gesehen
lul
ich wusste mal ich wusste mein headset weg machen sonst hätt ich euch zu laut ins ohr
geladen
lul alter wub lul wub lul jetzt können wir unser emote mal verwenden
wub lul
das ist schlecht
okay weiter
okay okay
weiter ich muss mir das noch mal angucken ist zu zu zu geil
tntv nach wetter things
tippt tippt wirklich glaubst nicht
tja meine serie ist schon mal auf dem bildschirm jetzt frage ich mich
oh huge subscriber crelex twitch prime
dankeschön nice
ja meine serie ist schon mal auf dem bildschirm jetzt frage ich mich nur wo mirko bleibt
der wollte mich eigentlich auch noch vorbeikommen ich rufe den mal an
hallo magenta ruf bitte mirko an
ja scheiße wenn du leute in der in der in der adressliste drin hast die vielleicht so
ähnlich heißen oder oder du vielleicht zwei leute kennst mit dem gleichen vorname
wird angerufen
ja kein problem ich hab sehr gemütlich guck meine serie alles gut ja bis gleich
telefonieren funktioniert also auch aber da geht doch noch mehr
neben den steuerungsfunktionen der telekom services bietet der smart speaker auch andere
anwendungen wie die abfrage des wetters das erstellen und verwalten einer to do oder
shoppingliste
leute beide sachen beide sachen wetter und to do
255 fps wetter und to do
ich weiß nicht ist euch mal aufgefallen dass wetter und to do beides quasi die hallo world
der etwas fortgeschrittenen programmierer sind
wetter und to do also alle die über hallo world raus sind und mal eine neue programmiersprache
ausprobieren machen entweder eine to do app
oder eine wetter app
das macht ein programmierer auf halber arschbacke
das ist wirklich easy as fuck
wir haben sogar im stream mal um irgendwie was wollten wir testen
äh blazer blazer zu testen haben wir eine to do app gebastelt in einem framework was
ich in meinem leben noch nicht gesehen hab das hat keine ahnung eine stunde gedauert
hera tricks lp dankeschön huge huge brain subscri...ups falscher knopf...subscriber
ok wir gucken wir gucken jetzt weiter
ja bis gleich ja bis gleich
ja telefonieren funktioniert also auch aber da geht noch was
neben den steuerungsfunktionen der telekom services bietet der smart speaker auch andere
anwendungen wie die abfrage des wetters das erstellen und verwalten einer to do oder shopping
liste oder dem abfragen von news außerdem fungiert der smart speaker auch als lautsprecher
hallo magenta
also wenn ein smart speaker nicht als lautsprecher fungiert dann weiß ich auch nicht
alle radio das ist der zuletzt gespielte sender
das sind die übelsten scheiß basic funktionen das das vor allem kann das sogar mittlerweile
jede 0815 open source spracherkennung easy hotword detection fertig das ist easy as
fuck mittlerweile nicht das nicht das vom scratch zu programmieren sondern äh was
zu verwenden was schon da ist zuletzt gespielte sender
hallo magenta
was eine musik radio funktioniert also und der sound stimmt auch aber was passiert eigentlich
mit den ganzen sprachdaten die hier von mir aufgenommen die werden ihr natürlich nie
im leben auf gar keinen fall es ist wer werdet ihr die speichern auf gar keinen fall kann
er kann nein nie in sachen daten hat der smart speaker einen entscheidenden vorteil denn
er bietet sehr hohen datenschutz nach den strengen deutschen sicherheitsstandards der
telekom und der europäischen datenschutz da habe da ist mein vertrauen ist die daten
gespeichert die den betrieb des geräts oder die dienste des smartspeakers ermöglichen
außerdem hat der kunde jederzeit das recht einzelne daten oder auch komplett alle seine
daten zu löschen die daten werden natürlich nicht an werbetreibende oder dritte weiter
gegeben hinten am gerät gibt es außerdem einen mute knopf das heißt ich kann jederzeit
selbst bestimmen wann das gerät aufhören soll mir zuzuhören das ist die einzig sinnvolle
funktion die ich bisher in dem ganzen video gehört habe das ding hat eine mute knopf
ihr seht also smartspeaker ist nicht gleich smartspeaker wie sieht das denn bei euch aus
seid ihr fans von diesen e-sport die telekom erklärt leute das müssen wir gucken ok wir
gucken uns doch die die telekom erklärt uns e-sport das müssen wir so angucken ja das
kann man sich entgehen lassen die funktion würdet ihr euch vielleicht noch wünschen
schreibt gerne mal unten in die kommentare kanal abonnieren ich vergesse wenn tf jetzt
mit level 6 meine lane gänken das fängt ja schon an ach du scheiße das komische kreativ
hat in den senna als er hat sein ist das oder ist es ein senna als er hätte ich weiß ich
so ein stellzbomber herz hat 5 3 3 2 3 dankeschön gut danke für den sub ok leute wir müssen
stark sein wir müssen wir müssen die bewertung an wir müssen stark sein der frazier der
frazier das kann nicht der originale frazier sein der frazier dankeschön für den sub
ein stream ist besser als das tv-programm ich finde es auch gerade sehr unterhaltsam
hier ok leute jok oder joykeel dankeschön twitch prime primers hier im chat so viele
primers huge prime so wir gucken uns hier cringe das cringe telekom video an ok wir
müssen jetzt stark sein wenn tf jetzt mit level 6 meine lane gänken dann ist meine
lane lost ja jetzt ist toni e afk ein bisschen was moderieren toni ich mache nämlich gerade
hier das ist toni also bäm bäm bäm e-sports ist in den letzten jahren nämlich ein richtig
großes ding geworden fans feiern ihre lieblingsspieler wie superstars wie der alltag eines professionellen
gamers aussieht und was e-sports ist nicht mal in game ja stimmt der gänkt überhaupt
keine lane gerade außerdem gänkt man keine lanes das war sogar ich als jemand der noch
nie lolly gespielt hat man gänkt spieler und keine lanes eines professionellen gamers
aussieht und was e-sports mit netzqualität zu tun hat das schauen wir uns heute an bei
den netzgeschichten ausverkaufte arenen jubelnden fans sechsstellige preisgelder und millionen
zuschauen ja wenn du lanes gänkt heißt aber du gehst auf die lane und gänkt die spieler
in der lane oder ich bin ja der huge big brain moba spieler also ich hab ja überhaupt
keine ahnung von ja siehst du e-sports brechen sämtliche rekorde diese ausmaße sind doch
der wahnsinn oder wir sind heute zu besuch beim sk gaming team die jungs spielen auf
der premier tour das spiel league of legends das strategiespiel gehört übrigens zu den
weltweit erfolgreichsten und meistgespielten wie gut wie gut ist das klar in lol also ich
meine sind keine koreaner die können nicht übertrieben gut sein aber wie sind die so
außer korea außen vor wie sind die geht so ich glaube viele andere aus deutschland haben
wir nicht oder ich kenne mich in moba szene null aus e-sports titeln unterstützt wird
das team von der telekom ach deswegen ach deswegen wird sk gezeigt wichtiger sein als
ein starkes netz von den profis habe ich mir erklären lassen worauf es tatsächlich ankommt
nämlich auf den sogenannten ping steht für die zeit die die vom spieler eingegebenen
daten bis zur server und wieder zurück das können zum beispiel karakterbewegungen oder
aktionen im spiel sein je niedriger der wert desto schneller der abgleich mit dem server
und desto größer der vorteil gegenüber spielern mit einem höheren ping die grundlage für
den erfolg ist also richtig eine qualitativ hohe netz performance nun aber zu den profis
wie seid ihr denn zum gaming gekommen überhaupt aber mir war es über die schule also meine
freunde haben mir das spiel gezeigt damals in der sechsten klasse noch und dann haben
wir einfach ansprachen zu spielen anfangen ist natürlich nicht bewusst dass ich irgendwann
mal professionell spielen kann aber ja ich bin man viel verdient als deutscher lol pro
ich meine selbst die koreaner verdienen jetzt im vergleich zu anderen spitzensportern jetzt
nicht irgendwie millionen oder so die koreaner machen wahrscheinlich relativ viel drum herum
ich frag mich halt wie es in deutschland ist einfach immer besser geworden über die
jahre ich habe einfach immer weiter gespielt das spiel hat mir immer mehr spaß gemacht und ja
irgendwann haben meine freunde dann halt aufgehört und ich dachte mir war das macht mir immer noch
mega spaß ich spiele weiter und ja dann bin ich halt immer höher und höher gekommen und irgendwann
kommen auch die themangebote teams werden auf dich aufmerksam wenn du weit oben bist und gab es
irgendwo einen punkt wo ihr gesagt habt jetzt ist es nicht mehr hobby sondern wirklich irgendwie
job ich finde es ist schwierig überhaupt freizeit zu definieren weil bevor man wirklich so das als
job gesehen hat war das ja eigentlich seine freizeit die man die ganze zeit reingesteckt
hat deswegen sehe ich das teilweise immer noch als freizeit weil es mir spaß macht es gibt
allerdings natürlich auch phasen wo man nicht so lust hat vor allem auf solo q also mit meinem
team machen ist eigentlich immer spaß zu spielen aber hat alleine so den cure ist überall über
sequencer kann man ein bisschen frustrierend sein ist es denn wichtig irgendeinen ausgleich zu
haben zum e-sport ist schon sehr sehr wichtig damit auch der der geist so ein bisschen man
sagt ja healthy body healthy mind das stimmt ja auch so ein bisschen und also versuche ich
zumindest so drei viermal die woche ins fitnessstudio zu gehen und sonst halt so ein paar
transformationen ein bisschen einfach ein bisschen ausgleich haben was ganz gut ihr seht also
gaming macht eine ganze menge spaß aber es kann auch echt ganz schön anstrengend sein und genau
deswegen dass der beitrag der beitrag ging doch sogar ich mein es ist ein team was von
der telekom gesponsert worden die telekom macht werbebeitrag warum nicht ja das ging doch noch so
und jetzt wollten wir noch gucken telekom smart home ihr smartes home vorstellung aller produkte
weil es gibt schon vier jahre sogar ich vorstelle
wie heißt das eigentlich heißt das als das magent magenta magenta smart home
guck mal das video von der csu das haben wir haben wir vorgestern also schon geguckt es
war schon winch genug magenta smart home da brauchst du unbedingt magenta smart home
für die kaffeemaschine bindest du dann nicht so ohne weiteres ein sein ist ein extra extra
magenta home kaffeemaschine hast du einen festen streamplan oder wenn bock der einzige feste
termine wo wir immer streben ist sonntag morgens das sind die längsten 46 sekunden die ich je gesehen habe
was ein schwachsinn ok erste anrichtung smart home sagt mal her telekom was habt ihr zu bieten
die einrichtung von smart home erfolgt in fünf schritten das ist langweilig email und
in die weiße fahre eine sekunde fahrt ich weiß gar nicht warum ich mir den ganzen krab von der
telekom holen sollte es ist es ist es wirkt es wirkt immer so wie gewollt und ich gekonnt so
nach dem motto smart phone ist smart home ist angesagt ja wir machen jetzt smart home
o game streaming ist angesagt wir machen magenta gaming oder o alexa ist angesagt wir machen
jetzt magenta smart speaker den krabb kauft kauft wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal jemand
die telekom sollte mal das machen was wofür sie da ist zwar mal endlich weiter glasfaser verlegen
was hältst du von telekom car connect das habe ich mir noch nicht angeguckt keine ahnung
ist aber für mich auch irrelevant
ja genau das ist richtig richtig kingwall das ist für die alten rentner die in den
telekom store um acht uhr reintappen und sich das antreten lassen exakt so siehts aus wahrscheinlich
ist unten drunter tuja cloud oder sowas
glasfaser ist neu ja dazu fällt mir nur ein glasfaser ist neu dazu fällt mir nur er hier
ein sehr im internet unterwegs bin nicht so sehr mit ihnen und mit twitter und so weiter aber seit
den 80er jahren seit 1980 ist er im internet unterwegs ja also von wegen dass da noch mal
irgendjemand vorwürfe machen könnte dass da irgendjemand keine ahnung hat seit 1980 der
ist der ist länger im internet als ich auf der welt bin ja überlegt euch das mal das ist der
wahre experte hier so feil so feil drei stunden 30 was da los leute eigentlich ich habe keine ahnung
was ich erzählen soll ich habe kein schimmer mehr eigentlich bin ich fertig ja ich muss mal
gucken ob ich jemanden hosten kann oder gibt es irgendwas was man sagen muss unbedingt also wir
haben jetzt wir haben linux mint heute getestet ich muss sagen linux mint scheint mir wirklich
super distribution zu sein für leute die ein bisschen windows style desktop mögen sehr rund
sehr schick alles dabei was man braucht ich habe noch nicht das fiver verpasst ja wie man
es nimmt also wir haben uns am anfang ein bisschen was von fiver angeguckt aber eigentlich nur die
leute die abgesagt haben ich habe noch keine ich habe noch kein code bekommen von den fiver leuten
bin ich noch eingeloggt bin ich mal eingeloggt nee dann kann ich kann ich jetzt nicht nachgucken
zu wenig deutsche leuten auf twitter auf twitch weiß gar nicht wie ich hosten soll immer hier
sein sind die deutschen namen noch am start gerade auf deutsch hotpack tech talk hacking lernen
kotlin java zeug zs go custom der hexa auf eine andere maschine sprich auf meinem kali
das kali linux aus den richtigen hexa am start kali linux gibt es eine lustige geschichte
zu ist das letzte wahrscheinlich was ich euch erzähle auf der arme hat man einer
kali linux installiert in der vm und weil weil er tatsächlich sagen wir mal er hat
verschiedene hacking tools gebraucht hat er ein paar sachen scann wollte also nix da hat
er auch eine position gehabt wo das ok ist und auf einmal war sein netzwerk port nicht
mehr ab und es kam in den security mensch rein gewetzt und hat gemeint was er da machen würde
da hat wohl irgendwelche locks im proxy also wir haben wir haben wir haben so ein darf ich
sagen was das ist wir haben wir haben eine antiviren software und firewall die quasi von dem antiviren
hersteller die können auch proxy scannen und so und das ding hat er wohl gemeldet dass da
super krasse hexa tools runtergeladen werden und jetzt muss alles gesperrt werden
haben sie übelst panik geschoben welches programm ist das links das linke in der taskbar
noch mal in der wind aus startknopf ich glaube nicht dass du das meinst was meinst du denn
das da das da das da mal du meinst es grüne aber wer das gefragt wer das gefragt flintstone
das half life symbol meinst du das das sind kommando kommando zeilen fenster das ist quasi
ein ersatz für ein ersatz dafür weil der wind aus weil das wind aus terminal übelst
sagt standardmäßig und das ist ganz gut und das ist chromium soll ich habe keine nicht
den ich hausen kann heute oder doch wir können den hexa eigentlich hausen aber ich habe ich
habe hunger ist das kein ich habe euch extrem gefallen denkt dran wenn ihr noch primer subs
zu verteilen habt umso mehr leute sammeln umso bigger der iq von allen die zugucken wir machen
schluss ich hoffe euch hat es gefallen morgen gibt es neues video ich bin auch gerade dabei
habe heute angefangen ein bisschen mal den serverraum umzubauen ich habe gedacht ich bin noch
bis mittwoch gar nicht geschrieben kann ich jetzt mal was sinnvolles machen ja macht's gut wir sehen
uns bis denn zu